and i want to make sure that we get
everything we are paying for
out there with my good friends uh sir
max tag marks or eric weinstein let me
just
check on my feeds if this is actually
working
you never know with technology
artificial intelligence has not kept up
with what we can do with it but we are
live oh my goodness
429 of our closest friends are watching
the three of us
and if you guys can hear something
please put in we hear you
in the chat in the live chat please put
in a we hear you
eric how are you i'm doing well max how
are you both here
can you guys hear us out there yes hello
awesome we're live oh my goodness
welcome
everybody what's that
eric you keep you started uh just
blinking out i'm not sure what that is
oh it shouldn't be happening everyone
hears us that's good
put a thumbs up in the uh in the uh
thumbs up region if you can hear us and
put a thumbs down if you
don't want to hear us and you can mute
us but welcome to
dr brian keating's rocking new year's
eve with
with two of my good friends max tegmark
eric weinstein
guys i can't thank you enough for
joining us today we're going to have a
fun conversation to end
it's really been like a fun year for
everybody right nothing bad has happened
this year
where are you guys where are you guys
weathering weathering the storm that has
been 2020 max where are you
currently joining us from home and the
great metropolis of winchester
massachusetts
ah winchester and eric where are you
joining us from today
an undisclosed location somewhere in los
angeles
those are the scariest ones of all when
i was a kid in new year's eve we'd watch
uh
pro wrestling you know which is maybe a
moniker i don't know how professional
you need to be but anyway
it would always be the scariest
wrestlers were from parts
unknown like they don't know where like
the guy didn't put it on his resume
where he's from
uh well the undertaker can't be from
middlebury connecticut
that's right he has a small candle shop
and uh he does some scrimshaw
in there uh but uh boys we are here you
guys were
last gracing my presence this summer
together at least
although you were separated in time when
my channel partnered with
pbs spacetime studios matt o'dowd and
his team
on a discussion of theories of
everything and we had two live streams
over the summer i'll put links to those
in the uh in the notes box below
but since then we you both have been
involved in some really interesting
kind of side hustles i think and uh i
think the
the audience would be appreciative if we
could talk about
how things have gone since that
summertime soiree
pair of soirees where i should say you
two were not on the screen at the same
time but uh
but so today is the chance for for three
men to enter and then no no
there'll only be all three of us will
exit because we have new year's eve
plans tonight
uh max what have you been up to since
this summer's theory of everything uh
shinde well aside for
from some remote teaching and torturing
mit freshmen and
with physics i've been spending
a lot of time on this attempt to make
our
news a little bit less lousy
i think we have such amazing
opportunities to do great things
as a species as long as we actually have
a clear idea of
what's actually going on i think
things have gotten pretty uh notably
worse
on that front than in recent years as uh
partly because uh online media has gone
online and put so many
traditional journalists out a bit out of
work and even more importantly because
just machine learning algorithms
have started to create these filter
bubbles and new tools for manipulating
people to be a
really quite poorly informed of what's
happening it's
the basis of doing good things in
science is always step one you know
figure out where you are that's what i
want to help
and eric what about you uh this has been
a very peaceful season i'm sure
uh in your corner of america what have
you been thinking about ruminating on
well in part i've been trying to get
past the election i actually
because i've been politically active i'm
very concerned as
max seems to be about the news but also
the way the meta news and our
integration into the news is working
and i'm particularly distressed about
the attempt to control
intellectual thought as if it is
subversive
you know undermining of of the country
with everyone picking on either russia
or china or some nefarious group
the trump family and the idea being that
if we will just
trust um you know the washington post or
dr fauci
or mitch mcconnell everything will be
okay and i don't
and i don't trust youtube and i don't
trust google i don't trust things that i
can't talk about
and so i'm particularly distressed about
the idea
that we're entering an era in which
things are so serious that we have the
we
have an obligation to get people who
disagree with consensus off the air
because they are subversive because i
don't know how we make prog
if we can't tell the difference between
cranks mavericks
heterodox thinkers geniuses and all of
that stuff we are toast
and it's you know imagine if we said um
that we max tegmark overnight can't
show up to his office at mit because in
fact um he's
he's producing harmful conversations and
i i just can't imagine that
all of our institutions other than
trader joe's and maybe coinbase have
capitulated
i'm so glad to hear you say this
actually it's very refreshing
because um richard feynman you know is
one of my superheroes
like to say that the essence of science
is
don't trust anybody you know not even
yourself and your own
your own your own prejudices right and
uh
science had to fight really really hard
to get this ability to start challenging
everybody
if galileo tweeted that hey
the sun is actually not revolving around
the earth
and then the pope fact checkers say
fact check this violates community
guidelines
it's actually the sun going around the
earth
that would not have gone so great and in
fact
things the 1600s version of that kind of
happened to galileo
we fought so hard against for this
freedom as scientists
to have everybody count equally and yet
here we are now you know
in if you're in china and there is a
government that tells you this is
what the truth is if you're in north
korea you have a government that tells
you
what the truth is and and now somehow
it's a good idea to try to have i think
there's there's a lot of good intent
behind the fact checking today
but if you say that there's some
committee
at some big corporation that has a
monopoly of what's saying what's true
that's exactly the opposite of what
we've learned from science all these
times
in science there is no we acknowledge
that it's hard to figure out what the
truth is
right that's why we didn't want the pope
to say it or or
kim jong-un my papers get refereed by
random other scientists right not by
some appointed uh
comedian at a company right
and i think that you know in some ways
and yet it moves is the original harmful
conversation
uh and you can imagine if the pope put a
little tagline under it saying this
claim is disputed
uh by experts everywhere the key thing
is understanding the the difference
between mavericks
cranks and what i've called knarks and
of course mac
because you're swedish you'll appreciate
the word knark which is cranks spelled
backwards and they they sit
at the center of our establishment and
they do
cranky things from the chairs of
greatest respectability
and it's very important to me that
canarchy behavior
be distinguished from cranky behavior be
distinguished from heterodox behavior
and i wanted to plug
max's effort fqxi which is an attempt at
non-cranky heterodox thinking in physics
and now beyond
and it's the leading organization sort
of analogous to the institute for new
economic thinking in the economics field
of course the perimeter institute was
founded and the santa fe institute was
founded in this regard this has a long
tradition and i really think that
even though we may be doing this on
youtube and things youtube needs to butt
the hell
out of the idea of we know what reality
is and we'll let you uh
post about it or not as we see fit
because that's just that's going to
grind society to a halt and we're not
having it
yeah and if it were so easy to actually
find out the truth
science would be done all of us
scientists should be fired we could go
home right you just have some government
officials or corporate officials
saying this is true this is false right
this is why we need science in the
future we can consult the truth and
safety
the trust and safety committee and and
they can finish it off we don't need the
ai to tell us
the secret so uh speaking of youtube
as some of us make our living from you
to now i'm just kidding i i don't gavin
newsom my boss if you're listening out
there
i'm hard at work as you can tell every
day
uh but these podcasts do uh and kevin
newsom bite me
oh seriously youtube bite me we we we've
got to stop
looking at our incentive structures yes
they can shut us all down tomorrow
let's stop cow towing and groveling in
front of people who don't deserve it
should we talk some science yeah let's
get into that but first i want to ask
you something uh frivolous
which is that i promised i swore eric
that if anyone came out of this pandemic
with a six-pack i would kill them
okay and you my friend have done that
you've you've dropped seriously i said i
dropped five pounds
from my double chin to my stomach but
you have come out with a six-pack i
wonder was this part of your new year's
resolution last year and what is your
new year's resolution each one of you
guys
this year i think they're very important
to make new year's resolutions eric what
is was yours last year
what's yours for 2021 um
i forgot what mine was for last year i
think for for 2021
um i'm going to push out geometric unity
as uh in written form wow
okay you heard it there here first
ladies and gentlemen i am
this is the first time i've said that
too and i am uh going to provide
whatever meager
means of support i can provide to do
that maximilian
you're worth maximillion dollar i
remember when i met you i said is your
name maximilian you said
i'm not a millionaire yet so is 2021 the
year you become a millionaire
and get some of that elon musk quan or
what do you what do you want to do in
2021 you do so many things so well so
so interesting you s you just suck the
juices out of life what do you have
plans
for in plan uh for 2021
money is never something i've
particularly cared about
i have two new new year's resolutions
one
is to
take the improve the news project which
i mentioned
and make it way better i have a lot of
ideas and people a lot of people have
sent me a lot of ideas
for um
doing something much better than the
sort of fact checking that we were
whining about here which is much more
science inspired and make it easier for
people to actually find out what's going
on
that's my nights and weekends job and
then on my day job
is to do some really awesome research at
the interface of
artificial intelligence and physics i'm
so fortunate to have an amazing group of
students and other colleagues to work
with at mit
and so i was sitting yesterday looking
at all these project ideas and ranking
them
and just feeling so excited and wishing
that 2021 would be
much longer than 365 days
well we're going to talk a lot about
time as we continue here
first of all i'm going to start taking
some questions from the audience
and i think well so there are people
asking what does max think about
geometric unity there are people asking
what does eric think about
max's mathematical universe i am willing
to go there if you guys are but
that wasn't the pretext in which i
tricked i mean invited you guys to come
on
uh but so but but i think it's
interesting to get a status report
maybe on the theory of everything side
and then we'll turn to
power of ai in physics and different
projects that you and i
aren't interested in eric and max so
first of all
what are you guys thinking about let's
just say your own field your own
projects and then what if you don't want
to comment on the others
project at least the value of having
multiple projects and i'll say this very
lovingly but to my friend sabine
hassenfelder who's got a wonderful
channel
of hers and she's really amped it up and
upped her game and she's one of my
kind of role models i'm trying to look
up to she has said that you know she
basically doesn't have time to think
about
these new theories of everything whether
it's it's it's eric's or
stephen wolfram who's been on the show
or garrett lisey or even maybe max
tegmark so
what do you think though of the value of
pursuing alternatives to
the dominant paradigm which is i would
say it's probably string theory right
now for in terms of a candidate theory
of everything max you go first
what's your what are your current
thoughts on theories of everything other
than your own
i i think it's i applaud people pursuing
the full spectrum of of theories as i
said earlier
if it were so easy to know the truth we
wouldn't need science we'd be done right
and uh it's very unhealthy to have an
intellectual monoculture where everybody
is looking under the same lamp post
that's not the best search algorithm to
find your keys
or the theory of everything um so
in fact my main our meta algorithm as a
scientist which has served me
surprisingly well is that if i noticed
that the whole herd
was going in this direction
i would usually come in a different
direction look there
because you never become the first to
find something if you're just following
others
right and eric what do you think about
not only
uh you know the value of gu or the
status of gu
for example i was gonna i thought i was
gonna do max and max was gonna do me
oh yeah max do you well max max do you
want to comment on
alternative theories of everything
well i think uh
if you i think um maybe for the benefit
since we don't have time to get into
something
super detailed and i still haven't had a
chance to read the paper that you've now
officially pledged that you're going to
write
next year maybe you could just very
briefly summarize
a core an idea or a theme for the
benefit also of our readers and then
they can comment on that
sure um well then let me go first
and then then brian call take max and
i'll try to integrate something into to
tee it up for him to spike
to dunk on me rather okay so
the first thing i would say is that i
don't think sabine is being truthful
um and i think that she's being polite
she is a ferocious and fierce uh a
friend of physics uh who cares very much
about the honesty of the subject but
she's personally
really saying something else which i
think we should say that she doesn't
believe that these theories are worthy
of her time because they don't have a
certain genetic qua
that suggests that they are effectively
correct and
the cost of exploring them seems high
so i i want to not take sabine's
particular gift of her diplomacy
and lean too heavily on it she has the
time to record music videos she just
doesn't think that this crop
smells good enough in order to dig into
it is what i really think is going on
and i think that that's really common
because what's really
suffusing the field is a sense of
hopelessness where we don't really
believe that anybody is on the verge of
the theory of everything in the way that
dirac and einstein were pushing things
for
forward at the beginning of the 20th
century now i also disagree i don't
think that's where we are i think we've
been stalled out for almost 50 years
in a certain sense not in others i don't
think that string theory is still the
leading candidate
or if it is it's only because it's
greatly diminished and nothing else has
taken its place
i think max's mathematical universe is
an interesting
issue i i i've come at it from a
different way
so i've never actually had this
conversation with max we can find out
whether we dovetail on this
but i say sometimes that the theory of
everything or fundamental
physics is really the one place that we
have where we think that the map
may be the territory and that's a little
bit of the way in which i
interpret um the special nature of the
theory of everything and
and some with the lens through which i
understand max's
ideas which is that the math is the
reality not that the math
models the reality then there's some
extra stuff which says that all math is
effectively created in
in a physical instantiation in some
sense on
on that i will remain silent because
it's only the sector that i have any
direct tangible experience with
i think that that's quite possibly the
truth we may be looking at things
that where the map and the territory are
not distinct
like greenland is the map of greenland
um
as for gu just to be quite clear about
it um
my take is that we haven't owned up to
the fact that the final step
is different than all the previous ones
and is conceptually much harder and so
my attempt was to say
can we drag three generations of chiral
fermions with the particular sorts of
interactions that we see
plausibly from a radically simplified
hypothesis
so that we get everything emergently we
don't get something from nothing but we
get something from
almost nothing this is sort of inverse
to the garrett lysi method where what
you do is you take the
most complicated simple object in the
universe that sounds like a
contradiction but isn't
and then you find the baroque complexity
of our world
inside it using something like e8
what i do is i start with four degrees
of freedom and i say einstein made it a
very interesting mistake and a beautiful
one
which is that he started with the
concept of space time
and that space time is the picking out
of a particular system
of rulers and protractors responding to
the matter on the four-dimensional
extended structure called a manifold but
that what we should be looking at is the
original
four degrees of freedom the proto space
time together with all possible rulers
and protractors and that creates a
14-dimensional world
called a bundle of metrics and that each
individual metric
is like a periscope going between the
four-dimensional world and its
14-dimensional emergent extension
and just the way if you poke your
periscope up in the arc
arctic and you see a polar bear uh
hunting a seal
you're receiving the image down below
inside your submarine and what we are
currently experiencing in my
understanding is that we are in a
14-dimensional space
looking at it from a four-dimensional
space via the metric which is the
pullback
is what we would call a pullback it's
the agent
of pulling back the data from 14 to 4
and that the 10 dimensions of
rulers and protractors that einstein put
his 10 coupled differential equations
are in fact the same 10 dimensions that
would crop up
in grand unified theory of the so-10 or
spin 10 variety
or more important the petit salaam
theory
which is spin 6 cross spin 4. you take
10 dimensions and you break it into sort
of two pieces if you will
and that that arises naturally from the
way in which
the 10 rulers and protractors emerge
from the 3-1 components and to dovetail
the two
brian you asked me before whether
wolfram and i had a connection
i think max and i actually have a much
richer connection than wolfram and i
have
i would say that the four zero one three
two two uh three one and zero four
sectors all exist
but that we'll never meet them because
we can't get to them
and it may be that we are in anthropic
sectors that support life i also believe
there are only two generations max
not three the third one is an imposter
that would unify
differently with particles that we
haven't seen
and that the world is not actually
chiral but only emergently chiral
and in that uh light gray in low gravity
environments it appears to be chiral but
if we were near a black hole or the
beginning of the universe
we would suddenly see a lot of matter
that now appears dark coupled to the
matter that we are
so i take it you haven't it's not a
question of whether you've read the
paper i released an
episode um on geometric unity
with video from the oxford lecture and
that that sort of a quick
fly over if you want to if you want to
start uh hunting fish in a barrel
yeah you'll be proud of me for actually
having
watched this video this morning even to
get it fresh in my
my memory here very interesting stuff i
i i really agree with
um with what you with um
what you said there in that there i
don't see any any particular
disagreeing incompatibility between what
you're saying
and and what i'm saying uh first of all
um
it's very striking that even though you
did talk about a polar bear you know
that was an example and really reaching
out to my swedish brethren
everything exactly everything you
everything you said about
uh the theory itself was mathematical
and um it's interesting as well if you
talk to string theorists or
loop in quantum gravity fans you know
their theories are utterly mathematical
as well
there's really no leading contender i
would say on the market for a theory of
everything right now which is not
mathematical so it uh it's not so
shocking in that context to talk about
the idea that maybe the ultimate theory
is mathematical
and and then another another very
strong commonality is you you said
yourself here right that it's
pretty natural in your theory that the
ultimate physical reality that exists
is bigger than the part that we actually
have access to
and can see and i i find it kind of
emotionally amusing that
so many people get all twisted up about
this and all stressed out about the idea
that there could be things that actually
exist
physically that we can't access
it seems so arrogant to me i mean if
you're an ostrich
and you stick your head in the sand
should you really be arguing to yourself
that
if i can't see something then it somehow
has no moral right to exist i mean if
you start the other way around
whether just the premise that there is
some stuff that exists physically
why should we be so arrogant is to think
that it's all going to be accessible to
us
it seems like a kind of hubristic
starting point the um so i'm very
interested in and when you finish the
technical paper seeing more about how
the details actually
come out because the devils are always
level is always in the details
as well as let me see let me say maybe
two more things philosophically that
sort of
uh give a grounding i think one of the
reasons that we have failed to unify
physics very successfully i mean
obviously we had maxwell
and then glacial georgia glacial
weinberg and salam those are the great
unifications that we've had to date in a
certain sense
but i think that part of what's going on
is is that we are unifying
into an uh intended structure
um and that the structures that we will
end up unifying into are actually
tensions between structures so for
example
my guess is that two of the four main
equations if we go field by field
uh will i will unify into one equation
the dirac
and the einstein field equations
whatever succeeds them
i have in one equation and uh
the yang mills and the equation
governing
the higgs field which we would call a
modified klein gordon equation
would modify would unify into a
different one and then one
of those two unifications would
effectively be the square root of the
other
the other is that replacing space-time
by a pair of spaces rather than a single
space
so in essence things unify into
into pairs and there are tensions within
the pairs
but one of the things we've done in our
radical reductionist heyday
before any of us were born was to try to
unify
things too simply into a single
structure that is not capable of
supporting the weight of what we know so
i i claim that there will effectively be
two equations one of which will be the
square root of the other there will be
two spaces that replace
one single unified space time and that
weirdly we've got everything
slightly wrong if we had it wildly wrong
we would figure out that we had it
wildly wrong
and if we had it absolutely right we'd
be done and so weirdly we're sort of
slightly wrong about everything
including three generations
it strikes me that you don't max have an
initial recoil
how can that how can there not be three
generations or how can matter not be
uh chiral or how can how can space-time
be dispensed with uh those are the
things that i was expecting to
have to look i if i've learned anything
as a scientist again
it's to have a very open mind and be
humble
as we talked about earlier we need to be
about everything
it's it's easier to do when you're
tenured tall and good looking but i get
it it's incredible guilty as charged
it's incredibly hard to um
take an equation a simple mathematical
theory
and predict what is it going to feel
like
to observers who live in that world
right yes
and uh in the case of what galileo did
it was so the correspondence is so
direct that it was easy
you you said here is a point in the
mathematical and euclidean space and it
corresponds the position of my apple
it's moving whereas already when you got
to einstein
it it was
super hard the genius of einstein wasn't
that he was the first person who was
able to write down the equations of
special relativity right which
are relatively but that he was able to
unders understand what it would feel
like to live
in a world governed by those equations
it would feel like time slowed down
you went fast then you got shorter and
other weird things
in general relativity it was even harder
right it wasn't einstein who invented
romanian geometry
but he was the one again who was able to
translate the math into predict physical
predictions
and realize that it actually made sense
quantum mechanics
has taken us yet another level up where
we've had the equations
now we've had the schrodinger equation
now for almost a century
and our colleagues are still arguing
about what it means exactly so
that's exactly why i i do not allow
myself to recoil
when someone puts out some equations
where it's not obvious how that's
exactly going to match reality because
that is exactly the thing we've learned
is so hard yeah i want to ask just a
related question to that
i've had a conversation with uh paul
steinhardt who's a
the einstein professor of natural
science at
a place called princeton university i
know max knows him well they were
colleagues together uh before they both
jump ship
from a certain ivy league institution
that i won't name because i have good
friends and good colleagues there but
um but i want to talk about a
conversation i had with paul and he said
he didn't know if he could come up with
things like inflation or
pyrotic universe or things like that in
the age of social media
in that uh you know as soon as he might
have some tentative idea
as you know eric described to me once
you know we were sitting in my office
here in uc san diego and he's writing on
the choppy like what did einstein think
in 1914
1915 1916. finally 1917 you know it
evolved and
numbers changed the equation changed
maybe the meaning didn't fundamentally
change but in an era of social media
by the way i'm going to take one quick
break to remind people that carpal
tunnel syndrome kills
750 million people every year in america
alone
so exercise your finger hit the like
button if you're enjoying this a thumbs
up on
on facebook or youtube hit the subscribe
button i put links to
max's youtube channel which needs some
love max
you've got about a thousand subscribers
we're gonna amp that up right now
uh subscribe to eric weinstein's channel
as well i put those in there the portal
subscribe to dr brian keating's channel
if you like conversations like this
in the age of social media where you
have sensors
in a certain sense uh that have cell
phones instead of uh
instead of you know swords well what do
you think is the probability that you
guys could have and come out with
theories or
new models can come out uh because
necessarily
you guys are theoretically inclined i'm
experimentally inclined we don't really
put out results until
you know it takes years to make an
experiment but were you guys making
theories
or making conjectures about philosophy
and the nature of reality
how has the impact of social media
stifled you
if it has or does it stifle creativity
of young people in particular max we'll
start with you and then we'll go to eric
well i think it's always been rough
throughout human history to uh be
contrarian and
one's ideas and i have to say i was
under no illusions when i was a grad
student
being super excited about these big
biggest questions that anyone else was
going to
care in any way whatsoever i i used to
joke with my friends if all i worked on
was this
you know my next job was going to be in
mcdonald's so i just accepted that and
said that's i'm not doing this
for any kind of public recognition i'm
doing it because
i love it that's the best reason to do
science so i i would
make i didn't even tell my thesis
advisor about the first
these four papers i wrote as a grad
student i only showed them to him after
he had signed my dissertation i just
kept doing enough mainstream
stuff on the side that i could you know
get another job afterwards
and it's actually been been quite
surprising to me that
many years later some of those old
things that i thought no one
is ever going to care about now some
people are actually
building on them and and doing things
with them but
i think the most important thing is to
do science for the right reasons
the right reason to do science is this
is the greatest detective story ever you
know we get to be part
of this amazing mystery solving
about our universe and its nature and
its origin and
destiny and how cool is that to get to
be part of this scavenger hunt you know
and connect with these great minds
throughout history
that if that's our motivation then
we will never be disappointed it's just
going to be a bonus if anyone else ever
cares
or tweets yes absolutely spoken like an
intellectual heroin addict
i'm exactly the same way max my feeling
is is that the problem of
this detective story as you say i
haven't heard somebody call it that's
that's great um
is that it competes pretty well with
money
uh and sex and drugs and anything else
you can come up with it's hard to find
anything
that you know if you offered somebody a
billion dollars or a peek at the
actual understanding of the universe
there's no question that i wouldn't be
taking a billion dollars
[Music]
there is nothing like it and people
often say science is fun i don't really
think that's true most of the time it's
just really difficult and it's often
boring
but it is the most deeply fulfilling and
at times peak exciting thing you can do
with a human brain
it's astounding to me that something
that we use to find food and water
can actually understand partial
differential equations it's very very
confusing that that and no it's a it's a
genuine mystery
um with respect to the uh
the general question remind me brian of
its formulation
what uh creativity of an einstein oh
yeah no i remember
can i just chime in while you're
clarifying the question they're also
say one more just personal thing i want
to share that i think is so rewarding is
uh precisely because i think about the
grandest questions
simply because i love
the the being part of this
mystery solving it it also means that
whenever i
run into other people like you eric or a
lot of other physicists
who who obviously do it just because
of that reason then
i feel a really touching kind of
brotherhood sisterhood
with these people right even more
broadly just going to physics like every
single one of
my colleagues in the mit physics
department could easily multiply their
salary by
pie if they went and did
something on wall street or whatever
right and they don't
right and that makes me feel also
a really cool kinship you know here all
these people who have chosen
to make much less money to follow some
these things that they're passionate
about and
we're this just makes me feel so
uh excited and honored to get to be part
of a community
of people who are doing things for this
reason
so i remember your formulation i think i
think what brian what uh
max just said is incredibly important
imagine that if eddie van halen could
have been a hedge fund manager
and multiplied his assets you know would
it have been worth it and we wouldn't
have eddie van gaal and so it's really
important that things
are able to compete with money and um
that's very tough when when inequality
is so high but it's really
also important that we boost the amount
of funding to scientists i just want to
be very clear about that
the thing that you were saying before uh
brian about
social media there's an interesting
feature there's two kinds of really
negative behavior that affects a lot of
us when we're working on heterodox ideas
there's trolling
negativity where people are just taking
a piece out of you and the cookie cutter
sharks are tearing into your hide and
extracting their little core of fat
and swimming off happy that they've uh
you know they've trolled you they've
dunked they've drank
they've dragged blah blah blah then you
have the same
phenomena in a weird way coming from
your academicians
and the academicians i think the biggest
intellectual offense that i ever
experienced in physics again i'm not a
physicist but
was hearing string theorists say well
string theory isn't threatened because
if you do anything outside it will just
tell you that it's string theory and so
we'll absorb you
and i thought wow cool what a wonderful
advertisement that
your theory can't be wrong because if we
come up with anything you've
you've kept the naming rights to say
that what we do is strength theory
um i think that that negativity from our
colleagues and the negativity from the
trolls has a very important effect
what if really great theories
were found by people who were not highly
disagreeable
now i've i've disagreed with the susan
wojcicki even though i'm on youtube
with gavin with gavin newsom i've said
that sabine hassenfelder is lying that
she doesn't have time for these theories
i'm obviously highly disagreeable
doesn't mean i'm i'm not personable
but i've been cultivating th this very
trait
because it's necessary to do science
when
everybody is wrong so in the great
financial crisis
i was part of a very small number of
people who were saying this whole thing
is going to blow up naseem tele was
another one
and he was disagreeable enough that when
i quit this game of going on conferences
and saying hey
mortgage-backed securities are posing a
real threat
naseem said you're going to regret
crapping out in 2005. you need to stay
the course and i said everyone's
laughing at us
i don't know whether you're not paying
attention you're not hearing he says no
you're not getting it you you're you're
bailing out of the trade before the
trade is actually mature
and i learned a lot from the scene nasim
is incredibly disagreeable
on the other hand you need people
who are like richard fireman and one of
the things i might do on the portal this
year is to read his letter of
resignation from the national academy of
sciences
where he didn't want to say why he was
but he just didn't want to be hooked up
to his peers
and you know max when you were talking
about the fact that your peers are other
physicists
i'm very concerned that we have too much
group think in physics
in physics and we need to be flipping
the bird
collegially and constructively to our
colleagues as well as to the trolls
and i do see that there's a lot of
commonality between academicians who
huddle around respectability
peer review the idea of their accolades
whatever rewards and prizes they've been
given whatever their title is
and that too much we the academicians in
an
era in which we have not been advancing
some of our fields quite as quickly as
we used to
have become prisoners to the little bit
of respectability that we have
left and we need to reclaim the right to
be highly disagreeable without
constantly saying
that everything comes from consensus the
most depressing part of this
is the idea that the so-called great man
theory of science
is under attack by people who claim a
priori that it is always communal when
anything happens which is preposterous
particularly when you think about how
singular
somebody like a dirac was or an einstein
was
and or a fineman or a paulie or a
weinberg and all of these people are so
individualistic to all of us who've read
their work
that we have to recognize that we are
under some generalized social attack for
what it is that we have proven
beyond any doubt we do which is to use
single individuals disagreeing with
their entire
community and getting the entire
community to come along after the fact
very good so let us take a quick break
and uh have a musical interlude while i
queue up some questions because we have
questions
max has a relativity song oh he does
okay well
i know he's uh he was one of the
original members of abba getting back
together
uh this is by my friend uh miguel tully
who's
uh runs the yeti tears website and other
things so
i'm going to just look for some fun
questions and then we'll get that queued
up
so i'll put up another in the meantime
oh yeah there's a yeti that's right i
have a yeti tumbler somewhere around
here
full of vodka getting ready for this
rocking new year's eve you're joining
max tag mark dr eric weinstein professor
max tegmark and yours truly brian
keating
on a special edition of the into the
impossible
podcast all right we have a question
about entropy one of max's favorite
topics
this is by jeremy payne why is the
entropy at the beginning of time
low but the entropy in a black hole is
so high
ah wonderful question why is entropy at
the beginning of time so low and the
entropy
and the black holes are high first of
all i said we have to be humble and
so i'll be the first to say we actually
don't know that the entropy was low at
the beginning of time
we don't even know if there was a
beginning of time that
that's how how humble we have to be here
what we do know
what what i do feel we've learned which
is quite
uh remarkable is that you know first of
all entropy for those of you who aren't
who need a bit of refresher is a
physicist
measure of how messy things are so my
room then
from here where i do this tends to get
higher and higher entropy
messier and messier why is it that you
see things getting messier why is it
that you've seen eggs fall on the floor
and break
and not see them fly up and unbreak
people argue about that for a very long
time
until a shock this shocking insight came
that
the reason that that
the entropy is lower is higher now than
it was yet
that it was lower this morning than
before i dropped the egg than
now is because it was even lower
yesterday and the reason for that was it
was even lower the day before that
and the reason for that was it was very
low 13.8 billion years ago
at the time when those uh images baby
pictures of our universe were given off
sitting right behind you on the sofa
there brian the causing micro background
and so on so somehow our flow of time
towards greater messiness has something
to do with our origin of our universe
that i feel we have learned so that's
progress
but now the question of why was that is
something where
many of my colleagues disagree violently
with each other i have
written the paper there which i think
it's fair to say
has very little support let's just say
what it's
concluded anyway which is that if you
take seriously the
idea of inflation and also the theory
that the wave function does not collapse
according to you everett you can do some
math and
and get an explanation for for why that
happened but i think it's a
it's a wonderful mystery um and um
i'm open to all ideas for what what the
deal is with this
and and black holes came up here of
course
which is something else we know very
ultimately where there are great
truths i think yet to be discovered so
we have a question from
a uh person with a very lovely name i
should have used it for one of my
children uh the name is just given as r
uh but r
asks uh eric uh what advice would you
give to a young person pursuing a phd
in mathematics as you perceive uh
pursued
back in the 1980s i believe
take an advisor what do you mean
i didn't have an advisor and i did not
understand
that and it you don't need an advisor to
do mathematics you don't need an advisor
to come up with new ideas you need an
advisor to negotiate the system
and in effect
the way in which we regulate population
in mathematics
is that just like many avian species
we don't feed certain chicks and if you
don't get fed as a chick it doesn't
matter how good your ideas are
so in large measure your advisor
is somebody i didn't want an
advisor but i had i had to try taking
one then it didn't work out and i just
decided to do it without and then it was
forced upon me you'll find that i can't
fix my wikipedia entry because the
system insists that raul bott was my
advisor a lovely wonderful human being
but he just didn't happen to be my
advisor
the thing then that i would say is once
you had to take an advisor
you need to have a really frightening
conversation with that person
where you come in and you say i know
what my odds are and if you are not
willing to swing for the effing fences
i'm going to die
you've assessed me i want you to tell me
where i stack in my chance of viability
i don't care about anything else
i want to know whether you think i am
viable and if so at what level
and if that person is not willing to say
i think you're one of the top people and
i will fight tooth and nail to make sure
you survive provided you do what i think
you're capable of
get out and you will not have that
conversation
because you're going to be a [ __ ] about
it and by virtue of not having that
conversation
you are going to find out later that
when that person withholds
the high praise necessary to secure a
job for you and to secure
opportunities for you you will then
wither and die
and if you'll
just look at the survival rates if you
can't get to one of the top four or five
departments it's almost not worth going
that doesn't mean nothing good happens
below that
but what you're dependent on is a system
of selective pressures in which your
parents
have to kill and feed you for a period
of time before you can hunt and kill for
yourself
and that situation is one in which you
are going to be squeamish and your
advisor is going to intimidate you away
from asking the questions but quite
frankly having done research in this
area for the american society for cell
biology
advisors usually form an impression
almost immediately
whether you are viable or not then your
department will extract labor out of you
for a period of time
your advisor may get you to work on
subroutines for their career
and then your carcass will be discarded
and if you do not understand that this
is what has happened
in the academic hunger games uh you will
not be able to defend yourself the fact
that nobody's talking about it
uh you watch nobody in the university
system will tell me that i'm wrong
they'll just tell me to shut up
now max when you when you are approached
by a young beaver
mit what what do you look for
in a promising young phd candidate or
you've done a lot of work with
undergraduates but i recall you being
a very lovely mentor to me as a graduate
student when i was at brown and you were
at penn
but even before that when you were a
post-doc i recall
are good advisors born or are they made
oh that i actually don't know but i i i
will uh
and do my best to answer the rest of
your question
and and maybe first before i even do
that i'd like to just
add a little bit to what eric said there
because you painted a very
very uh scary sounding image of
of academia you mentioned hopefully many
times and being devoured and and
everything like this and for those out
there listening or considering going
into a job of academia i i
i actually
feel a lot more optimistic about and i
would like to give a more optimistic
end-of-year message for those of you and
say
go for it and don't be scared off by all
this talk about death there
first of all you have to remember that
if you go into academia
and for some and you have this vision
that you're going to stay in academia
for the rest of your life
and it doesn't end up that way
what will happen is not that you're
going to be
starving to death somewhere in some
corner but that you will instead end up
in in doing something else where you're
going to make a lot more money than
than you would have in academia and most
people i know who have left academia
are seem quite happy
so there's really not much to be afraid
of the second thing i would say is uh
yes it's i agree with you it's very
important to have an advisor who can
support you i agree with you there eric
uh
i also think um if you wanna if you're
like
eric and me and brian and you're
fascinated about big questions
but maybe very unfashionable at the time
and have ideas that are unfashionable
uh i say pursue them anyway but have a
but do it as a scientist with a where
you have a really scientifically valid
game plan also for how your career is
going to work nonetheless
right where you spend some of your time
doing what your heart is burning for
and then some of the time just making
sure
that your career is going to be fine
anyway so you know you eric
have solved it by making money in other
ways so that you can continue
doing the great science that you do
right i similarly
developed a strategy very early where i
i that i confessed earlier where i would
just
write enough mainstream papers that i
could stay in academia
and then on nights and weekends and so
on i would um
do the things that i was really
passionate about in other words as long
as you have a
sort of scientifically or sound business
plan
for how your career is going to go right
then um
don't be afraid of falling isn't it also
a challenge that we have
you know i'm uh as some of my listeners
know i'm a pilot and i am actually a
commercial pilot not for
you know wanting to deliver passengers
or mail or
tow banners over the san diego seashore
i do it because
uh when i'm learning i am becoming a
better teacher
and if you stop learning in aviation you
die and so one of the things i started
to do a few years ago is get my
flight instructors uh rating and to do
that you need to be a commercial pilot
first
so i got my commercial pilot i got my
and then i started looking through well
what does it take to become a flight
instructor
it turns out the federal aviation
administration
has one and only one to my knowledge uh
branch of government
that has in its handbook for
practitioners of this federal agency
it has the words love can you imagine
like the irs
like to be a good irs uh auditor you
have to have lo
no you have to have the opposite of love
in some cases uh
no no offense out there i mean eric made
fun of youtube that's more powerful than
the irs so
but uh but it has maslow's hierarchy of
needs encoded in the handbook of
testing for future flight instructors
like me hopefully
and i wonder i never got sat down uh max
i don't know if you did
by my dean or my stodgy old dean or and
they never said well here's how you
teach you need to make sure that your
students
feel a sense of love david spurgle is
famous for saying that his best piece of
advice is that
a student needs to feel loved no
obviously it's platonic
but um but but the student needs to feel
a sense of love
but when did you ever get taught how to
be a good teacher and maybe eric
you're suffering because your true
advisor maybe didn't love you enough and
that's saying maybe you need more a
little more
true advisors i know that that's what
i'm saying you're a self-made man eric
and you're in love with your creator
sorry i i i'm passionate about something
here that i need i just need to
to say in a different way i love the
fact that brian and max and i
are trying to take our passion for this
subject but you're taught
if you're watching this live stream or a
recording of it
you're looking at three of the most
anomalous
people in this game having a
conversation
as if hey you can do this too my
situation is so exotic
that i can't recommend it max you know
admitting that he's effectively chosen
the superhero route you know mild-mandar
clark kent by day superman by night or
you know bruce wayne or who knows what
look here's what you need to do go to
the math
genealogy project okay look for
everybody
who was a uh for the survival rates of
advisors before
1972 and the survival rates of their
students
after 1972. we had an actual
singularity happened in our markets in
around between 1971 and 73.
and if you look at somebody like norman
steenrod who stopped advising
and when he died i guess in the early
70s almost
all of his students survive and if you
look at anybody
like the top advisors today they can't
match
that previous thing so max is quite
correct you can bounce
into a certain number of technical
fields if you do it at a high enough
level
many people don't make it to google they
don't make it to
great six-figure jobs that you know give
them fulfillment many do
depends where you're going i'm trying to
give you the tough love
max is trying to give you the optimism
and i think it's great having both go
look at the data
and ask every department that you're
applying to can you please show me your
outcome statistics and show me how well
you've done
because we're all lying about the fact
that since 1971 through 73
academics has been in a depression
period the end all right max how do you
react to that
i didn't claim the op i wasn't lying i
didn't
i didn't have said nothing to dispute
the fact that there is
that there's been a very sad development
and and the support from society and in
terms of funding for academia
and that that's just the way it is i and
i think
i wish it could change but even in this
it's in the
poor situation we are now you know where
the amount of money spent on
all physics funding in the united states
in a year
right is less than a couple days of
military budget
even in that state i think going into
science is
a really good move if you're excited
about it and i would encourage listeners
to do it and
here is here is my data that you asked
for i
you know really really get attached to
my past students and i try to keep in
touch with them
over the years and and to the very best
of my knowledge
every single one so half a dozen of them
or so are professors now
uh a bunch more probably will be a
number of them have
left and gone into other fields but
every single one of them
to the best of my knowledge is quite
happy with the fact that they
did science first and we and let me just
finish
here so so um i think that
there's no real indication that it's a
recipe for
an unhappy life to go into science and
contrary wise
uh as long as you have an
exciting time while you're doing the
science and then maybe later you do
something else you know what's so bad
about that you know you're we're all
gonna die anyway for real
at some point that's not an excuse to
not make the most of life
while we're still alive right and um let
me just say
say something very quickly which max
can't say
max is also exceedingly conscientious
and concerned about this by founding
fqxi
and giving even small grants to people
a lot of what max has been doing has
been taking care
of the heterodox community in all of
physics
so you're looking at in some sense the
most anomalous person in our space
well i act as the anti-matter to him
then i'm the worst advisor possible as
my students will
test them you're in a different area
we're talking really really theory for
the most part
max and anthony aguirre the the
co-founder i don't know how you guys
um these guys are serious about trying
to keep the field afloat and max is
not is coupling his optimism with the
fact that he's going above and beyond
what almost anyone else is doing and i
think it's fantastic that's why i love
hanging out in this live stream
but i just don't want to give the
indication that max is somehow your
typical performance
there's obviously survivorship bias
that's coming in here but i
have to say as i said earlier one of the
names that max will recognize is my
friend chris o'dell
who is the graduate student who came
after me at peter timby who is my
advisor and peter timby
is coming on the into the impossible
podcast so those of you out there get to
hear
from my phd advisor what a schmendrick
uh i was back 30 years ago brave guy you
are
i just love him and he's going to talk
about his advisor david wilkinson
uh who max also knew but max was like
this when he was a postdoc so i think
max is pretty naturally gifted in this
way
i do think that as we learn about
quantum mechanics max or as we learn
about
uh you know topological field theory or
whatever uh eric does
we need to also spend time learning
about how to teach
how to manage how to lead i've had a lot
of nobel prize winning
experimentalists on my show lately and
the question i keep asking them is
how did like barry barrish and ray weiss
who led the co-led the ligo experiment
that won the nobel prize in 2017
uh they foolishly left their nobel prize
with me when they did the show
i picked the pockets clean after they
got off of my couch over there
but the point is we have to study these
soft skills and i think one of my
colleagues here darren lepomi does a
great job he teaches a whole
youtube and course about the soft skills
outside
of the laboratories i just wanted to say
that before we move on to
the question of academic funding and one
of the ways i am solving this problem of
academic funding is i'm accepting super
chats i am taking super chat now uh
this is not how i'm going to do it
actually though i do want to donate um
the proceeds from today to both of your
guys favorite charities you guys will
tell me afterwards
uh and it can't be you know to to the
brian keating fund
i won't do that but i'll donate all the
money i'm getting from the super chats
you're willing if it's the revolutionary
afghan women's association you are a
brave
i get their newsletter what are you
talking about am i willing all right i
subscribe buddy
uh and max will will obviously do it to
any of the projects you're interested in
so please keep those super chats coming
we have one from sweden
we have a swedish chrono max tell me if
this is a lot of money we have
100 swedish kroner coming from joaquin
peters patterson
who asked can i ask max and uh
and eric if they follow john williamson
thad rogers slash john mackin
theory of space-time as a fluid uh first
of all max am i going to be able to put
my
kids through college with this 100
swedish kroner and do you think about
space time as a fluid
with those 10 bucks thank you so i'll
have to say taxomic yeah make sure to
put it to
send it to a carrier that puts it the
good use
the um i clearly do need to follow this
theory since i'm
i'm the first to admit that i don't know
about as much about it as i should
eric you want anything about it eric
it's i got nothing all right fine we'll
move on next super chat we have 2
000 oh my god 2 000 russian rubles
which i think is about uh what eric
all right i thought you said something
all right okay are you are you are you
suggesting
russian collusion this is russian
collusion for eric weinstein uh-oh
eric do you think that the perceived
loss of information that happens
when a quantum system collapses is
because of equal probability events
present in the set of causal chains of
that quantum system
i.e is there no other distinguishing
factor we can identify i think he's
asking alexander apostoltov i can't
pronounce his last name alexander sasha
uh asking do you what do you think of
the perceived loss of information when a
wave function collapses
okay i don't think much about it i think
that
this has to do with the fact that we
formulated
quantum theory is going to be with us
forever but i don't believe it's going
to look
like it currently does with this sort of
deterministic propagation
followed by violent introductions of
probability when you ask
bad questions that is where the state is
not an eigenstate
of the observable representing your
question and i think that
a lot of what we have is we have a
theory that is good enough to work and
get results but is philosophically
unsatisfying
and the way in which we used to weed
people out in physics is that you had to
profess that you actually accepted that
this
is exactly the way the world works more
or less and my feeling is this is the
way the world works
relative to our current framework which
is
clearly telling us don't overdo the
analysis
until we get to the right framework i
think this is really what einstein was
saying he wasn't saying that he hated
quantum theory he said that he hated the
idea that we were going to
rush to say hey the universe is queerer
than we can suppose haldane was right
and wow this just proves that some of us
can accept it and some of you guys are
stuck in your classical world
i think that the problem is we've got
way too much g-whiz
in our physics and if g-whiz is fun
it just doesn't actually move the needle
so i'm always
up for trying to remove g-whiz to get to
the fun of
looking for a better framework and i
hope that gu will start to push in that
direction
can i add something of course brian so
priviata think that's a
that's the question about the wave
function collapsed there look i think
the wave function just does not collapse
this was the first way i got in trouble
in physics actually with a swedish
professor
eric you'll be proud of me for this um
we swedes never pass up an opportunity
to make fun of denmark and talk smack
about them so i'm good for you
we'll miss that sense now either james
bohr and the copenhagen interpretation
i respond with hamlet something is
rotten
in the state of denmark oh my god talk
about stockholm syndrome
uh look the wave function does not
collapse let's face it there's
absolutely no experimental evidence for
it it appears to collapse yes
but what you ever had showed so
beautifully already back in the 5th 60s
is that
50s and 60s is that even if it does not
collapse
if you just drop that entirely and just
say go with the shirt in your equation
all the way
it's going to appear like it collapses
and it's going to appear like it
collapses according to all the usual
copenhagen interpretation rules
and i would go as far as saying that
this
it doesn't even have anything particular
fundamental to do with quantum mechanics
it just if you have any sort of physics
which lets you make copies of an
observer classically or quantum
mechanically
you will experience apparent randomness
i like to imagine that
and i suppose you brian do you want to
clone yourself for the new year so you
can get twice as much done
uh yeah then i could you know we'll take
you into some san diego san diego
medical
center and put one we'll sedate you and
and i'm telling you now you're gonna
wake up it's going to be january 1st
2020 will be over one copy of you wakes
up in room one
the other copy wakes up in room two in
the hospital okay
what do you predict is going to be the
first thing you experience when you walk
outside your your
hospital room and look at the room
number my wife's going to yell at two
guys that look like me
at the same time but what are you going
to see are you going to see a room
sign that says you're in room one or you
see a two you cannot predict this
because you know there will be two
experiences one ex one brian experience
this is one one two so the only best
thing you can say is i'm gonna go and
i'm gonna look and i'm gonna say oh
this seems random i'm gonna either see a
one or two with equal probability this
is
what i think fundamentally is happening
in quantum physics too
the quantum reality is just bigger than
the one we
thought we lived in before quantum
mechanics and it has this ability that
it can start with something which
is in one way and make effectively being
in
two ways and and then when we make a
measurement sometimes
we find out which copy we were so i
wouldn't worry about
the way function collapse that's a
tremendous amount of technical debt
to go to many worlds to take on to get
rid of the
collapse of the i mean in other words it
it does strike me that what we've
entered an
era in which we can solve many of these
problems if you don't mind that we're
positing something
even wild i mean wildly more outrageous
it depends on depends on what you
measure
outrageousness in right if if what you
mean
is that something is more extravagant if
it if
it involves somehow having more
particles or
reality being bigger yeah then sure but
i think you and i
eric both feel that maybe the kind of
simplicity that we should value with
occam's razor is rather that the
the math is simple the equations are
simple
it's a very interesting point and i do
think that what
i'm not saying that max tegmark cannot
get out of max tech's technical debt
i'm saying that it would take
a very good day being max tegmark to get
out of max
tegmark's technical debt in in so doing
that
by the way you're much more partial to
the schrodinger equation than i ever
imagined
i even got my wife to agree to have it
hanging on the wall
that's his love that was his first tweet
to his wife
i love you dear there you go so we're
getting other questions that
i want to come to but i do think eric
and i have talked about this
um kind of the whiz-bang approach to
physics that
i believe is a little detrimental and
and your mutual friend lex friedman
up there has had on other characters in
addition to the two of you guys uh one
by the name of michio kaku
who will talk waxing rapsodically
about the mind of god and how everything
is encrypted and encoded and if we can
get to the multiverse and that really
would be the singular
i find that i like michio he's very
good as an entertainer but i think the
selling
of physics is going to come back to
haunt us and and kind of
the just touting this stuff and i'm
guilty of it at times too but
you know i won't end uh utter the mind
of god
what do you think about this the danger
that we as people that are publicly
facing
have of potentially compromising
the true appreciation of the most
magnificent things in the universe which
take a lot of
background you can't dumb it down and
you shouldn't
i will never do that with my audience go
ahead eric first
it's a really interesting and tough
question uh i i kind of hate it to be
blunt because i feel like a lot of
i mean let's let's be frank about this
it used to be the case
that we reserved the right to talk to
the public
in this fashion for the very top people
and they sort of did it sparingly and we
made
yeah we made certain um
you know it's one thing uh if you've got
gammoff talking to the public you know
great figures in your field
but somehow we've got these science
entrepreneurs and
you know i i would even i don't think
that's primarily what i am but
you could make an argument that i've
become partially a science entrepreneur
and i try to go away from this language
now if you ask me privately what
animates me
it's very tough when you're talking
about the
the basis of reality itself to say come
on
don't make too much out of it like what
the hell come on the only reason to do
this stuff
is that you're talking about existence
and
can you please speak more modestly and
less with less purple language about
um existence itself i don't know it's a
challenge this is what
you know i go to synagogue where i don't
believe but i
feel and i'm filled with the spirit of
uh of the service
that's one thing okay we are all singing
and praying together it's another thing
when you're alone at your whiteboard and
you feel
like holy [ __ ] i i am in an indiana
jones movie i'm so close to the base
to to the hardware the metal it's like
uh
it's uncomfortably close to religion and
i think that what i find is is that
weirdly we talk about the mind of god
for two reasons when we're getting
really
far away from success in physics and we
need some side hustle in order to keep
people interested by the way this is the
same language
that we in math and physics use to hit
on our potential mates
um you know we we talk about the mind of
god when we go to a party if we have to
compete with a guy with actual money or
who can play the guitar so
we pick that up as a bad habit but when
you're also when you're succeeding at
science
that's the other time that you start to
to to get into this and so weirdly
if i hear somebody talk about the mind
of god
i tend to think that they're either
getting really far away from success
or that they've gotten very close and
they've reminded themselves
holy crap you know when i'm doing my
stuff i'm actually
talking about something that is so
profound i can't even believe i'm
allowed to address it or have enough
information
to feel that after standing on the
shoulders of so many nested giants like
a giant matroshka
you know um we've got it's giants all
the way down and you're on the shoulders
maybe i'm gonna be the one that you know
each one of us
to to turn in the baton at the end of
the relay race
who am i going to be turning this baton
into what if i
actually what if you have a theory of
everything we don't actually spend time
with this
it's a terrifying idea that just as the
last land mass on earth was at some
point
mapped you just lost don wells remember
the uncharted desert isle of gilligan's
island with satellite imagery we don't
believe in in
i don't know that we would have said
uncharted desert isle
in the modern mariana and marianne let's
um
yeah that's what i'm saying don wells oh
don wells i thought yeah yeah
john wells right that's right and so so
my belief
about this is that uh you shouldn't
fault somebody for talking about the
mind of god you should just
ask yourself is this because their
research isn't working or it's really
working and in general it's almost
always the case these days that it's
because our research isn't working
so max i have a question about theories
of everything oh go ahead
of course simon on this one also whether
we over simplify whether
we oversimplify too much and whatnot you
know i really love einstein's quote that
we should
tell things as simple as possible and no
simpler
this is what i always aspire to whether
i'm
teaching a course or giving a research
colloquium
or talking to the person next to me on
the airplane and uh
i actually feel i was not
oversimplifying when i said
talked about the collapse of the wave
function there the argument i gave for
you in the hospital
that was the full argument it wasn't
some sort of done down version
if you think it through again on your
own free time i think you will
conclude that yeah you will experience
the parent randomness my clone calling
yeah and and then i if people come back
and ask me follow-up questions
i'm willing to go as far down the rabbit
hole as they want so you know
here for example is the schrodinger
equation again right
and what it's actually saying is that
the state
of the world that's this greek letter
psi there or this bracket around it
right it's saying that the rate of
change of it
is given depends on the current state of
the world and you do this operation on
it and for the math nerds
this is a linear operation which means
that if the actual state of the world is
this thing plus that thing
the rate then
the same thing the rate of change will
be the the
the operation on the on the some of the
two things
and and but what that just means is as
everett has
pointed out and many others have known
for a very long time is that
in some circumstances two different
solutions to the
this can do their parallel thing we can
talk at great length about
but the discoveries later about the
coherence and why it is that sometimes
these different parallel branches are
unaware of each other
and but my point is you know if you give
a science
nerd colloquium to to at a physics
department
i i think ideally you should also start
in the same way you start
discussing this with your grandma just
at the very high level you know
here are the cool ideas and then you can
go as deep as as the audience or the
listener
wants from there max it's not clear to
me
even listening to this i really liked
what you said in in the hospital by
sort of a sydney coleman thing where you
try to take the
majesty of quantum mechanics and you
divorce it from some of the accidents
which people confuse
confuse it with and so by coming up with
a classical version
i really like that what i don't know is
whether or not it's really an
isomorphism
to the same phenomena because what what
you did is if i
if i look at consciousness i think brian
goes to sleep in the example so
consciousness is paused
and then we have an action where you're
trying to treat consciousness like it's
mitosis
and we clone the thing or we call spawn
inside of a computer
and then there's the awakening so the
quiescent
is an important part of your story could
you have told the same story without
quiescing the system called brian
keating
if it happened so fast
much much faster than the time scale of
a tenth of a second or 100th of a second
on which brian
reacts i think uh the argument is the
same
although i think we don't have surgeons
that quick and sandy even in san diego
that's the accident but what i'm trying
to say it's not clear to me that it's an
isomorphism
indeed and we don't know for sure that
the schrodinger equation is actually
that accurate description of nature
either it's quite so exciting to see
what's going to happen
with the quantum computer efforts right
now might
will they ultimately fail because
physics isn't
fully described by the schroedinger
equation or
will they actually succeed you know this
is where ultimately our
mental friends will will uh so
give us crucial insights as to what even
the schrodinger equation like
you know this is the non-relativist we
know the destroying our equation is
wrong
well it's it's right it's not complete
well we can also take quantum field
theory and
what i'm trying to get at is that we
have a situation in which
when we talk to the public i'm very
sympathetic with what you're trying to
do
or even our colleagues the problem is is
that great analogies
you know i do i do a superposition
analogy classically with
change in your pockets where some of
it's in swiss franc some of it's in
pounds but the landing card says
is your change in either swiss francs or
is it in
uh british pounds and then the idea is
that there's no
both and so because the the multiple
choice answers don't list
superposition classical mechanics
remains mute and quantum mechanics
weirdly says i'm going to
convert all your money into one or the
other because the landing card
says it by some mystical process i'm
very fond of these things
the problem is is that even when you say
that you're removing these things
an astute listener can can often spot
wait a second that's not actually an
analogy because if i tracked it exactly
there was a sleight of hand sometimes
the sleight of hand matters i don't
think in what you were doing with the
schrodinger equation being
non-relativistic
that you were using any sleight of hand
i do think in the consciousness question
by not by not addressing the quiescent
of the system
it's not clear that that's actually kind
of a fair
fair point yeah so before we just
bring closure to this uh you know i'll
be the first to admit that
we ultimately don't know what's going on
exactly with quantum mechanics
my personal guess i i'm happy to tell
you because i like betting
is that even quantum mechanics is
probably an emergent
theory it may be an approximation of of
of something deeper
maybe we can get it out of gu somehow uh
but um
i also would guess i also would guess
frankly and here i am
i am guessing the opposite of your
of roger penrose who you had on here
earlier
that the gravity doesn't really
have much to do with this i think you
can look at being in a spaceship far
away from any
really any important gravitating objects
and do your little quantum
experiments with the stern gerlock
apparatus and you would get all the same
fascinating things happening i i think
blame it
i think ignoring gravity altogether
ignoring relativistic effects altogether
you can
you still have this thing that people
love fighting about and arguing about
what does the wave function collapse or
not and that's why i'm so interested in
um
and this kind of discussion we had where
you get at those very questions
without worrying about that stuff so
let's take a break
a dgi air horn for you guys uh that was
awesome
my sound effects are coming into play uh
so we we're
still sort of uh diverging from one
question i
was very curious to get both of your
opinions about and that's this issue of
funding in physics
and i'm an experimentalist you guys are
theorists uh
mostly eric says he's not a physicist
please eric you're an honorary physicist
now
we will make it it's up to you guys it's
not accidentally physicist
he's a real thing he's doing physics
things i'm very honored
i'd love to be thank you guys it's not
for me okay fine
anyway you come down here you're in my
lab you're a physicist anyway we've
talked about this eric but i want to get
max's take on it i feel
theory is in a sense um less costly in
other words
it's easier to make theories just like
it's easier it's not easier
intellectually but it's
there are more programs in the world
than there are different types of
computers
there's more programming languages than
than phone
models for example so i make the analogy
that theory is kind of like software
and experiments like i do are kind of
like hardware and
and therefore it's very precious but i
get a lot of emails i'm sure both of you
guys do
uh you know i've got this theory of the
early universe uh i need to you know or
of grand unification
can you help me prove it and i'll share
you know my nobel prize proceeds with
you
i actually asked that of adam reese and
he said yeah how do you think i won the
nobel prize in physics
uh but but in reality we there's there's
so many there's a proliferation of it
experiments are expensive i
am myself really at the whim of jim
simons
whose generosity has uh granted me and
my
300 colleagues on the simon's
observatory the privilege of building an
experiment which could potentially
reveal evidence more evidence or some
evidence
in some cases for things like the
multiverse or inflation
i want to ask you guys what do we need
in physics
uh that the tech industry does so well
in software do we need i've i had this
idea of a y
combinator you know for physics how do
we get more
either more experiments to look at
theories or
use existing data from experiments as
max has done
to investigate the consequences of
theory and and how do we raise money
for it uh for physics as a whole it's
the our crown jewel of civilization many
people feel
so max i'll start with you uh how would
you if you were you know kind of
uh responsible for for raising funds it
seems extremely difficult how do we do
it to promote it for the net benefit of
humanity
there were really two separate questions
in there right how should we do the
physics best
given funding and second how should we
get the funds so
for the first part how should we do it
i think uh i really want to avoid trying
to give some glib answer
to it because it's a strength not a
weakness
that so many physicists around the world
have different ideas of how it should be
done
we want to try look not just on all
under the same lamp posts
but search in many different ways with
many different approaches
for the second question how you fund it
so you can have a healthy diverse
community
of of people going after this great uh
mystery of how the world works right
there
i think um yes it's great that there are
philanthropists
like simon's that will listen enough to
scientists to actually
you know fund them but i actually think
it's also
a big mistake as a species if we um
don't create institutions and
governments
which support science there have been a
number of very nerdy
economic studies that have shown very
clearly that investing in basic science
is the highest return on investment
basically ever and
i mean you're the expert you can push
back on on this eric but
inventing the transistor you know just
basic basic physics research
um has has benefited uh
so much in so many ways you know
inventing calculus you know
it didn't cost that much but it's been
so so valuable so i think as a society
frankly
uh we have to think and this comes back
to the whole media question again you
know
there are much more people who have
heard about the kardashians than
who can name three living scientists
even let alone 20 right
we created a culture where scientists
are
not not only are they not particularly
known about
or viewed as role models or heroes but
they're even very
actively attacked by a lot of folks
with power for whom what the scientific
what scientists are saying is
inconvenient and
i really think that if we can one of the
best things we can do for science
funding is to just create a less screwed
up
media landscape where we actually
appreciate
how much we benefit from scientific
research
that governments will actually support
it again right now
it's it's pretty we spent two billion
dollars a day
or more in this country alone
on military right
if you could get a puny puny fraction of
that into scientific research we
wouldn't even be having
to have this conversation about how we
get funding for science has had an
analogy to the military and calling
theoretical physics the intellectual
equivalent of seal team six so eric
how would you fund physics or how do you
uh how do you propose that we
crack this particular nut
there are four basic arguments the first
one that i like the most
uh will fall flat but it's max's
argument
which is um so i'm not not
i'm not ragging on max i'm saying he's
got the best argument but it just
doesn't work
it's the greatest mystery in the world
you don't want to know how it ends
you're not interested in how the plot
develops that has to do with the fact
that we have not brought people along
if you can't understand you know the
mystery of chirality if you don't even
know what chirality is
and whether or not we're going to solve
it is not going to be interesting to you
it's like a murder mystery where we
don't even tell people what this
you know what the crime is so in part
that's on us we should be making the
greatest mystery
accessible to the public but it doesn't
seem to work then there's the military
argument do you really want do you have
any idea how powerful your physics
community
is and how much it is accomplished for
you and you want
you can have these guys for a pittance
on permanent retainer
to make sure that when something goes
bump in the night you've got the world's
smartest people at your fingertips on
speed dial
what is your effing problem that you're
that you're causing them to talk about
funding
i never want to hear the two of you talk
about funding again
in your lives it pains me that working
physicists
are constantly in this conversation let
me keep going with the arguments though
the next one uh you know is an argument
about the fact that physics
has doomed you since the early 1950s 52
to 54 we are going we are in the valley
of death
if we do not figure out a way to become
a space-faring civilization
you can kiss your indefinite future on
this planet goodbye
physicists without the wisdom of gods
became as powerful as gods in the 1950s
and we do not have a long-term plan for
civilization we've had 75 years of
unexplainable quiet
following world war ii because we
dropped two physics devices
uh in japan and scared the living [ __ ]
out of every sentient being who's paying
attention
and that is not going to hold and so you
were going to be in deep deep
trouble but the last argument is
probably the most useful one and it's
not one that i love
which is let's talk about your beautiful
taxpayer dollars
they don't exist most of your taxpayer
dollar is a physics dollar and let me
explain it
i'm going to start talking about some
things that come out of physics whether
it's
electron shells whether it's the
transistor and semiconductors max just
talked about in semiconductor
instructions that power your computers
and the devices that you're watching
this on
whether it's the development of the
electromagnetic spectrum
whether it's the world wide web that
came out of cern
i'm going to keep going and going and
going and
at the end i'm going to say how much is
left of your beautiful taxpayer dollar
that that you're so worried that you you
don't why should you spend it on us
this is one of the reasons why i'm not
accepting you guys calling me a
physicist
i don't necessarily even like your
community all the time
but this is the most important
intellectual community that has ever
existed and it is intellectually
offensive in the highest order to have
it
try to explain what it has done for you
the old joke which janet jackson made
famous is what have you done for me
lately that's the
that's the punch line suck it up
physics had signed the world's worst
licensing deal in human history
any time you want to and you want to
revisit that
and say what would be a fair price for
what i think we're repeating it
wait wait wait wait just let me let me
get to the end of the effing ramp
any anytime you want to readdress
how much physics has provided for you in
that taxpayer dollar and you want to
sign a licensing agreement in arrears
that covers the world wide web the
semiconductors chemistry blah blah blah
electromagnetic spectrum
be my guest and you will be watching
physicists
flying around with flying their kids
around in multiple private jets
and you will be you'll you will be their
private chefs
be quiet listen to what you've gotten
from this community it doesn't ask for
much
shut up suck it up and make sure that
these people stop talking about funding
which is
boring and it's also embarrassing but if
you want to if you want to let the u.s
at the mer to be at the mercy of china
if you wanted to
live with nuclear weapons where we're
not trying to get off this plan if you
want any of those things it's because
you're not
paying attention please find somebody
who is and talk about this locally with
them until you understand the situation
a little bit better all right max
maximilian i'm going to put the million
in there now max go for it
and i just have to say you know my
favorite movie of all time
is of course the one about your life
life of brian
what's the python and i we really should
try to re-enact this epic
uh skit about what have the romans ever
done for us
by saying what is this what has physics
ever done for us
so embarrassing the internet
yeah but besides physics besides the
internet and transistors what has
physics ever done for us
it's it's you should you guys should
maybe we'll do that but i mean
i'll get back my wife doesn't you know
much to her chagrin can't go back and
say well you know when i married you you
were you know 20 pounds
lighter and i can't well your cooking is
so good dear
no i mean you we didn't sign a deal
there are no deals so
the question is how do we go through
hold on hold on
yes i want to get to immigration also
eric because we're talking to an
immigrant
a dangerous immigrant right now uh but
but i want to i want to get to that in a
second
i do think there there's a kernel of
truth but let me just say this we're
making
the exact same mistakes it wasn't just
the endless frontier
qubits were invented by physicists guess
who's using qubits well quantum
computing is using qubits what is it
doing max and i are going to talk
later this year about about artificial
intelligence and some depth
we're making the same mistakes now it's
not only because of the endless frontier
van ever bush all these guys
it we are making it's built into who we
are we are not good
because we don't get training in it eric
we never get training on the financial
end of things that you
have a pretty natural ability uh to do
perhaps or jim simons does
i don't even be training in economics
fine you have a pretty natural
gift then but uh most of us don't so the
question is what do we need i
i made this this comment someone in the
chat room is suggesting blockchain
i thought about that too is there any
application a y combinator
for physics where we put people that
want to get the next cube but before
it's too late we're never going to back
monitor forget it we're never going to
get
a dollar for each email that was sent
that's not going to happen but
going forward do we have to make them
the same mistake that we made 45 times
in the uh 20th century alone
i i think i really don't want to have
this conversation i'll be honest with
you
i'm embarrassed that we we try to come
up with reasons that we have to reason
look hey public you know who einstein is
you know who fineman is you can't stop
talking about them
uh i'm not i'm not i'm not justifying
how do we go forward wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
i understand it there are lots of things
we can do
if we have funding to make the field
exciting
inviting to get the talent we have to
compete for talent with things that
actually pay
and to have people constantly focused on
their grants and all this stuff
we have devitalized ourselves i don't
think we need y
combinator any of these things if we can
save the system
i think brian what your secret question
really is is assuming we can't save the
system
how do we go to blockchain how do we go
to y combinator how do we
do this and i'm not done because i'm
concerned that
you guys need friends who are not
physicists to explain
what theoretical physics has done in a
new way
to people who are newly nervous about
this planet by the way i forgot to throw
in molecular biology which was largely
founded by who
physicists yeah absolutely right it's so
absurd
that when we make the argument it is is
if we
are insecure about what we have done and
i refuse to be insecure in front of the
public
we need more people max i mean is it is
it a lack of people that's holding back
physics finance i'm just talking about
funding right now i mean is elon musk
fundamentally limited
by the computing power that he has or
the number of bright engineers
that he has look i i
many years ago i i promised myself to
never ever
pity myself and i i think i've kept it
you know
i think it's important to remember that
the physicists are not the only group on
this planet
who uh
maybe don't quite get the resources that
they think they should have that right
there were more people who died of
starvation
this year than who died of covet and we
don't even really read about it in the
newspapers
because for some reason this is how
media works right
um there were more people who died of
tuberculosis this year and last year
combined than have died of kobe this
year
we don't hear about them either very
much because of the way the media works
so somehow uh i think we the what's
happening in science
that science isn't has trouble with
getting funding and also that scientists
have their opinions not listened to very
much it's just a small symptom of a more
broadly screwed up world and
maybe sometimes the just like in physics
sometimes the easy way to solve a little
problem is to go and
find unified theory the higher do it at
a higher level
maybe the easiest way to get science out
of it screwed up situation is just make
society itself
a bit more a bit less screwed up i don't
know what you think eric
i think we could what we could do is we
could try look let me say something
about your community again you can't say
the reason that physics is so powerful
is is that it does
something that no other community can
easily do which is that it
it gets the hybrid vigor of the dirt
of the if if i go to brian's lab where
he's building telescopes
it is as gritty as you can possibly
imagine to get
clean results you have to be welding
things and soldering all this kind of
stuff
on the other hand when i look at what's
behind max on his uh background
um it is the purest most beautiful stuff
it's like listening to bach it's just it
effectively
uh is this magical purity and by getting
the
you know it's like you're combining
these two most extreme things and
there's something about this
intellectual thought process that if i
wanted to cure tuberculosis
believe me i would actually go to
physicists if i wanted to cure problems
in the economy i would go to physicists
it's
what physics does in training if it
works and if we stop
going the path because i think physics
training is becoming less valuable all
the time unfortunately as we drift
but when physics works the the
combination of purity and and dirt
and also the fact that so many problems
are surprisingly simple once you get
past the incredible hurdle needed to
understand them
this is why the physics community is
always at the scene of every great crime
uh you know for humanity and so if we're
stealing
you know things away from uh from
malaria
or or famine or any things to make
humans happier and better
you're always going to find physicists
at the scene of the crime because
there's something in the training that's
fungible which is why when i forgot
molecular biology can you imagine that
your community
more or less founded molecular biology
and i can't even be bothered to remember
to remember it while i'm listing all the
things we've done it's preposterous and
because um when you guys say it it
sounds like you you're there with a
begging bowl
i prefer to have friends say it for you
you need
the elon musks who almost became a
physicist the mark zuckerbergs
the yuri milner's whoever to get
together and say hey
we need to agitate for our friends these
if you guys do it it won't work we need
to do it for now
third-party praise so let me give you
some applause right there max you want
to have a follow-up on that before we
switch to another topic if you guys have
time i don't know how's your time going
guys
i i love this but it's up to you i'm
good for
for a lot more of max's uh i just want
to remind people to go to max's new
project to check it out it's called
improvethenews.org
go to eric weinstein's channel on
youtube look up the portal subscribe to
the portal
uh and if you're enjoying this live
stream just hit the
thumbs up button stretch your thumbs
don't get carpal tunnel syndrome it
kills
800 billion people a year stretch your
thumbs hit the subscribe button hit the
like button if you're enjoying this
conversation because i'm having such a
good
time with these incredible brilliant uh
friends of mine that i'm privileged to
spend the time with
because of things like the internet that
we
love and hate and i want to turn now
back to max you have a quick follow-up
on that and before we get to some
some topless and practical wisdom from
the two of you
yeah so just to share a final thought on
this business about
physics and science more broadly and and
how to get people to how to get both
get people listening more to it so that
the world gets run in a more
reasonable way and also so that
they don't we don't have to do so much
begging uh i think um
physicists we we we have a certain
arrogance actually which which has
harmed us a lot uh and helped you that
we
we forget that we're in a bubble
and that we forget that there's actually
a science
of how you persuade people there's
actually a science of how to communicate
and other people
have studied that at great length i
would say that the average person who
works making cigarette ads
is much more scientific about the way
they get their message out
than the average physicist and i think
it comes not from stupidity on behalf of
the physicist but
from arrogance and that somehow no we're
not going to stoop so low
that we're going to be scientific about
how we communicate
right scientific about how we advocate
we have to get off our high
horses you know if you get invaded by
hitler's army you shouldn't just say
well you know
tanks are immoral we're going to fight
them with swords we have to be
scientific also about
standing up for ourselves and our ideas
and and so forth and i i
part of that another second mistake i
think we make is
forgetting that we live in the bubble
and and
spending much more time in fighting in
within our community of physicists
or within having one science pitted
against another science for a few more
tax dollars you know
losing sight of the fact that
there's a tiny trickle of money that
flows to all sciences combined anyway
compared to what goes
into the generic fruits of of lobby
corporate lobbying and
and and random waste you know so
so get out of our bubble again
if we look at the big picture it's kind
of pathetic really that you have
physicist biologists chemists
who together have built up most of the
wealth
of the world and managed to be so
incredibly
navel gazing and busy with infighting
and
old-fashioned and how they communicate
that
they have to come begging for money and
people don't don't listen to them
can we actually can i just tell it yeah
go for it quick story from uh
from the malaria
wars effectively there used to be a
problem where you had a tiny budget for
certain
diseases that affected large numbers of
people who didn't happen to live where
the money was
and um
right now yeah and uh but there was a
change
back i guess in the 90s maybe 80s 90s
where i remember jeffrey sachs taking my
wife peele milani
onto a phone call and she was trying to
figure out how to
allocate this tiny little budget and his
point to her was
it's immoral for us to be trying to do
this what we need to do is to push the
budget out
and to stop accepting the constraint
and that's part of why i was a little
bit resistant i
wasn't because brian was making bad
points about
y combinator it's that i i can't
i refuse to start thinking about this
problem in earnest
at this level this is such a clear
mismatch
that the first thing is to cure
our society wants to spend more money on
science and it wants to spend less money
on stupid stuff and by the way the
really big problem the really stupid
thing that we did
was around the ssc cancellation the
superconducting super collider where the
arrogance of the community did not play
well in washington as times had changed
and i highly recommend going back to
like 1992-93 in the congressional
hearings
and reading how pissed off congress was
that when they found the national
science foundation lying and then they
found the physicist buying too much art
for their offices at the s at the ssc
and things like that
so it's very important that we also do
our part
to say look hey we are going to spend
some money on art beautiful buildings
and things that make us happy we have
conferences in beautiful locations suck
it up it's a pit and stop
complaining on the other hand know that
we are serious as a heart attack when it
comes to using this money
for things that really matter sometimes
all of that
kind of luxury promotes the idea i went
to a
max conference in banff it's one of the
most beautiful places
but that facilitated lots of people
feeling that we could take the risks to
do new things
whereas if you're constantly keeping
people at a minimal level of sustenance
they you know necessity is the mother of
very mundane inves inventions
but luxury is also is often the father
to
real freedom to consider bold new ideas
and i really do believe
that in part we need to recognize that
we pissed people off in the early 90s
and we need to re-establish trust and we
have the basis to do it i made that
point to barry barish that
had the ssc not been cancelled by the
venality of my fellow physicists
he would not have won the nobel prize
that he left on the couch here
because he only joined eligo because the
ssc was canceled
and then furthermore the higgs boson
which was the primary
discovery of the large hadron collider
resulted in
two nobel prizes uh but not to any of
the experimentalists
and i wonder you guys are our theorist
what i made this joke with eric
he always hits me when we're in person
when i say like you know do you really
think of experimentalists
as like you know the joke is uh what do
you call someone who hangs out with
musicians
well you call him uh a drummer what do
you call someone who hangs out with
physicist an experimentalist back
in the 1900s people used to say that
einstein
was practicing jewish physics he was
doing theoretical physics
real men did aryan physics that was
experimental physics oh
how times have changed there's a few
jews who have won the nobel prize and
some of whom are fellow experimentalists
uh like ray weiss like barry parish and
others but the question is
uh what you know to what extent do you
feel like there
is a you know a difference of a
viewpoint as to the importance of
experimental scientists versus i
i mean i don't think someone you know
bardeen looked at the equations of
quantum mechanics and said let me invent
the transistor which will then power all
these cell phones
i i feel like a lot of these discoveries
are serendipitous
uh in theory it's kind of naturally
serendipitous whereas experimentalists
we kind of need to know what we're
looking for before we set out
what do you think of the difference
between theoretical physics experimental
physics max
first and then eric in terms of the
difference in similarities that they may
engender
i i think experimentalists experimental
physicists and theoretical physicists
have always had a
love-hate relationship with one another
where
deep down there was a very deep respect
both ways
and it's been a very very healthy
relationship as well
where experimentalists have discovered
new
things which posed mysteries for
theorists to chew on
and and theorists have sometimes taken
giant leaps of
and and motivated experiments that
wouldn't otherwise
have done it's quite obvious to me that
if you
had if you eliminated either theoretical
physics or
experimental physics the field as a
whole would have
gone almost nowhere i think
you know brian there are three
sort of categories of experiments
experiments that i don't find
particularly exciting
but i'm glad somebody did them then
there's
experiments like the cobalt 60
experiment that showed that the universe
was left right asymmetric where the
effect is so astounding and the courage
needed to say
i believe that this crazy suggestion is
worth
trying where i admire the courage as
well
as the skill and the
establishing it is so profound that um
i i think it's you know top level stuff
and then there's like weird stuff
i remember i think the nobel prize for
the
um discovery of the particles or the
fields that
communicate the weak force or the w and
z particles
i remember the description of stochastic
cooling
i think which was that simon vandermeer
had contributed
where it was like we're going to take a
box
where there are particles bouncing
around and we're going to keep
nudging the box in precise ways
so that it absorbs the energy from the
individual particles
and so that they will all get cooled by
virtue of the fact that we
can nudge this thing i mean it was the
most mind-blowing description
and part of what i hope to be helping
brian do
is to distinguish that there's an
experiment that has to be done it was
done we're happy that it happened there
was an experiment
that showed something absolutely
astounding
it's a different sort of a thing which
took courage and then there's
experiments that look like
theoretical physics but are even better
sometimes because they're actually
physically manifested
like stochastic cooling and in part i
think that
when we call it experiment we're not
doing enough to talk about the taxonomy
of different things that
us theoretically minded people find
amazing about what the guys who actually
get
in gals who get you know down and dirty
uh
doing the actual nuts and bolts
soldering and gluing
yeah when you think about though you
know who does a scientist
if you say the word scientist to an
individual they'll think of stephen
hawking
albert einstein carl sagan it's rare if
anybody
richard feynman they don't think about
experimentalist and yet
uh you know something like in my book
losing the nobel prize i make this point
like 70
of nobel prizes have gone to
experimentalist since 1940
and from my perspective you know we need
the kind of brian green's max tag marks
eric weinstein's of
experimental physics to communicate how
freaking cool it is because you can
actually get something done
in a day and let us know as albert
einstein sorry albert michaelson the
first
one of the first americans to win the
nobel prize he said that experiments are
like puzzles
the more you do the better you get and
every time you do a puzzle it's like the
rubik's cube
i'm trying to get the inventor of the
rubik's cube on my podcast i'll let you
know if i can get that done but cameron
vapha
you're a mutual friend of you guys he
was on the show he wrote a book called
puzzles to
unlock the universe unravel the universe
and i asked him
what do you what would you rather solve
a mystery or a puzzle and it was a
question i asked freeman dyson the late
great freeman dyson on this very show as
well
what it animates you guys is it the
puzzle solving that i like to do like
working on my car
building a telescope where i know
there's a solution maybe i'm not a good
enough experimentalist to get it done
but someone is good better than me can
get it done or a mystery that perhaps
has no answer max let's start with you
what do you prefer most in life
mysteries that may not be solvable or
puzzles which have a solution
that you can complete
love both i mean not if not being
solvable doesn't phase me i'd much
rather have uh
any questions i can't answer that
answers i can't question
we're going to go there on god in a
minute but keep going yeah it's actually
very much my mantra as a scientist
i i also feel that uh the whole
distinction between experimentalist and
physicist
the experimentalist ferdinand slip is
kind of uh
outdated and dissolving first of all you
have a lot of people who
work at the interface like
phenomenologists who try to connect the
two
then you have people like me i spent
five years building a radio telescope
and i've spent a lot of time working
with you and others on experimental data
but i'm mostly a theorist
and then you have entirely new er
different areas which are neither
experiment or theory in astronomy right
they're very
astronomers are very clear to say i am
an observer not an experimentalist
and uh and now we have a new field
computational physics
which clearly is here with us to stay
you know if someone writes
if someone devotes 10 years of their
career to do amazing super computer
simulations and developing new
algorithms
for lattice qcd with a goal ultimately
of computing the whole periodic table
from
first principles right that's not
theory it's not experiment
it's a little bit like being an observer
where you observe inside here
it's it's frankly a new field so
i think we probably better off not
obsessing too much about
artificial boundaries between are you
this kind of physicist or that kind of
physique yeah
i also i should say before eric you
respond but i always say that
experimentalists
don't have to be able to create new
theories but we better
understand the theories that others have
proposed well enough that we can make
beautiful experiments you know our
friend sabine haasenfelder she says you
know beauty is driving physics astray i
disagree with her vehemently when she
came on my
interview because i said all experiments
are beautiful even the ugly you know
chicklet and
chewing gum and coat hanger ones because
they're all teasing out
something that is going to reveal
something about the universe whether it
be through a null result as i'm used to
coming up with
uh or an actual positive detection these
experiments have to have a certain
symmetry beauty and naturalness about
them in order to succeed eric what do
you think about the
uh this this you know rather provocative
i think brian you've been on this and
uh you've had actually been very
influential in the
evolution of my thinking about this i
hadn't realized the extent to which
the theorists i've been so focused on
the fact that we seem to have appointed
about six or seven people to talk to the
public on behalf of all
physics that i was sort of not realizing
that all of them tend to come from the
theory camp
and they all tend to come with varying
amounts of g-whiz
which is partially good and partially
not good i'm not
entirely against wu and g whiz but you
need to do in the right proportion
i think partially what it has to do with
is the shock if
you know for those of us who program
computers now and again
sometimes you'll have a theory a theory
and then you'll instantiate it inside of
the computer and when the graphic
actually shows you what your equations
have been saying
you have this kind of surprise you may
have written the code you may have come
up with the equations you may have
designed everything
but the computer reflects you back to
you
and you're like whoa it works it's real
i mean i think i was maybe almost the
first i think i may have been the first
person
to actually draw inside of a computer a
three-dimensional model
of parallel translation that applies
in economics and when i saw it come up
i was just astounded
and i think it has a different beauty to
it
i wish more theorists were doing some
experiment more experimentalists
and let me say the negative thing for
the experimentals you guys cannot afford
to be so light on the theory if you're
going to actually
check our work you need to speak the
language of people
whose work you're i'm very worried that
there's going to be a translation error
and you're going to think that you're
understanding what we're talking about
with tensors and differential forms
and bundles but in fact we need people
who go back and forth so i'm worried
about the two cultures of cp snow
dividing experimentalists from theorists
and in part that's on the
experimentalists they're trying to get
by with antiquated language
as if you know tensors are still thing
collections of numbers that transform
according to rules which is not a good
way of describing them in the slightest
with that said i think that there are a
small number of very interesting
places where you see something that
sounds like a theory that's actually
experimental if you look at watson and
crick's
discovery of the three-dimensional
structure of the double helix
they went through a triple helix that
they built a model of which was an
embarrassment to them
they also went to a situation in which
um
they come up with the double helix after
the the parts are machined
and delivered to their to their uh the
room in which they're working
in some sense the double helix was an
experimental result
and if i can pick out another one in the
late 50s
there was this really anomalous thing
which i still can't quite figure out you
guys can inform me the bohm aaronoff
effect
was the last really significant
discovery
around plain old classical sort of
electromagnetism now there may be a beam
and some quantum interference and stuff
like that
but we didn't understand that the
electromagnetic field strength which we
thought was the real
object is not really the primary object
and the real primary object is something
called a vector potential
when it turned out that we had gotten to
the late 50s without even understanding
the most beautiful of our classical
field theories
in its totality it indicated
to me that what is the danger
of having a strict division of labor in
the pin
factory of science where you don't have
enough people who are able to go back
and forth and i really look back to
those guys like fermi
uh you know we're great calculators beta
who is a great calculator people who
did both of these things and
at a minimum we need to be
getting these people in the same rooms
and i have to be honest with you there's
a way in which i think theory has gone
into a worse direction
even though i'm closer to it because
there's been so
little in fundamental physics that's
been propelling theory forward
except at the level of the framework so
we now have a much better idea of the
framework of the theory we haven't been
idle but we found very little that's
profoundly new
coming from the theory side since the
standard model was put into
rough uh final form uh as it stayed
since the
in the early 70s and max what do you
make of the fact that you know everyone
sort of uh sacrifices themselves as
lenny suskin calls it that
they become popper ozzy you know they
become overwhelmed by this uh this
notion of
falsifiability first proposed in the
demarcation
criteria of karl popper great
philosopher i haven't
i've told this to eric but i want to say
it to you i feel we physicists have
math envy you know freud called you know
most people having certain
other kinds of i mean people talk about
physics envy but actually i think we
have math envy
as physicists because at least
mathematicians know that there are
formal limitations in the uh consistency
of their mathematical
formalisms in physics we're left with
popper as just like falsifiability and
i've made this case
many times with only with nobel prize
winners because i i feel like their
reputation is so stellar but but then
many of them don't want to
you know risk losing their the sheen on
their gilded
graven image of alfred nobel but anyway
i want to ask you
uh the fact that there's so much
attention given to wormholes
given to black hole singularities given
to the big bang itself
given to your favorite one of your
favorite subjects the multiverse
is this why you're going into like more
kind of hardcore or practical or
experimental
science because we can't ever see any of
those things let alone know that they're
real
so why is it that you know that there's
so many physicists that are overwhelmed
with the notion of popper
but yet are practicing and appealing to
the public the g
whiz mind of god is inside the singular
you know why is that
i guess there's a spectrum of questions
in there
one of them is uh popper yay or nay i
promise to
address that yes a separate question is
where do we draw the line between
science
on one hand and [ __ ] on on the other
yes
and
i would first of all say
so i'm going to say something which
might sound paradoxical i'm going to
defend popper
but attack a lot of the people who claim
that
in talking about black hole interiors
and multi multiverse or [ __ ]
and and saying they misunderstood proper
so what popper says is that you know if
i if i tell you about a theory and you
say max
give me one possible experiment that
could prove you wrong and i can't come
up with anything
then this is the scientific theory i
stand by that
i think that's perfectly fair and
in fact there was a fascinating debate
about evolution once between bill nye
and someone else and bill and i asked
the other guy if he could
name one thing that would persuade him
that creationism was wrong and he
couldn't
so there popper would come down on bill
nye's side
that said though i still think
many people have misunderstood popper
and
can awake too crude view on it well we
when we test in science
are theories so for example
if you have an argument
you and eric about what's really
happening inside of a black hole
you can never go there and measure it
and then come back and do a podcast
about it
right does that mean it's all bs
no it does not mean that what you're
actually testing instead is whether
general relativity
is correct as it stands because general
relativity predicts
a lot of things you can never test
directly with experiment like
exactly what happens inside the event
horizon but also predicts a lot of
things you can
test like the perihelion shift of
mercury like the bending of star light
by the sun
like the whole taylor pulsar like the
expanding universe
and and so many other things that we
study with a great precision right now
including again
the patterns on your beach ball behind
you there or the micro background right
and and so in science we have the
situation that if you
have you can you cannot dismiss general
relativity
as being unscientific bs because it is
testable
so if you fail many times to falsify it
prepare proper style then you have to
start taking seriously all its
predictions even its predictions that
you cannot
directly explain to the test like what
happens inside of black holes and
this is exactly the mistake i think
people make now analogously in other
areas
they'll take for example alan guth and
relinda and others
theory of inflation and they will
acknowledge
this is a scientific theory because it
makes a lot of predictions it makes some
predictions even for the micro
background
it's had many chances they get falsified
and it's survived so far
so we have to start taking seriously
also some of its other predictions that
we cannot test which is that space goes
on
far beyond that beach ball probably so
far
beyond that it's worth calling other
regions parallel universes for instance
so is that non-scientific no it's not
inflation is a scientific theory and a
scientific theory
you take it or leave it it's all or
nothing like you cannot say oh
you can go into starbucks and say yeah i
want this coffee but
without the caffeine in it that's fine
but you cannot say i want general
relativity
i'm just going to opt out of the black
hole prediction
yeah i'm in such a different place i
think i fee i fear that i'm going to
just put my
my foot in it but i'm going to fall back
on my wingman dirac
i don't know if you guys have heard of
him
he says uh a couple of things that are
widely quoted
it is more important to have beauty in
one's equations than to have them fit
experiment
now that's clearly the sound of of a
crazy person in some sense
the the um he goes on to say if there is
not complete agreement between the
results of one's work and experiment one
should not allow oneself to be too
discouraged
so why is this well it's because he
lived this
and one of the things that i'm really
against is the promotion of the
sanitized version of science with the
scientific method
and popper uh not
coming remotely close to how science is
actually
done so we so
like max just talked about the anomalous
procession of the perihelion of mercury
um the problem is if i recall correctly
when einstein first
formulated this he formulated it with
grossman in 1913 and then he
reformulated it alone and put some
specificity to it
in a weird way the 1913 thing was better
than his first
go at being concrete because he said the
reachi tensor is equal to the
to the stuff in the universe and that
equation doesn't even make sense because
it's not it doesn't have a particular um
equation that it has to satisfy work out
but it was good enough if i recall
correctly
to explain the process the anomalous
procession
as a result you can have a wrong theory
that works with experiment and then you
can have the reverse situation
which is uh where um
derock was really getting this he says i
might tell you the story i learned from
schrodinger of how when he first got the
idea for his equation the one that max
held up
he immediately applied it to the
behavior of the electron and the
hydrogen atom that is the simplest
possible system
and he got results that did not agree
with experiment this disagreement
arose because of the time it was not
known that the electron has a spin
and that of course was a great
disappointment to schroeder and it
caused him to abandon the work
for months then he noticed that if he
applied the theory in a more appropriate
way not taking into account the
refinements required by
relativity to this rough approximation
his work was in agreement with
experiment he published this first paper
he goes on to say that this wrong
equation that max held up
is not in fact the equation that
schroedinger had to begin with which is
now called the klein gordon
equation so he didn't have the dirac
equation which is relativistic or the
klein gordon he came up with
a wrong equation it's called the clan
equation because it was invented by
schroedinger and i
it pains me to admit it's because client
was in sweden
but the point that i'm trying to get at
here is you can have situations where
you get agreement with experiment your
theory is wrong you can have
other situations where your theory is
right but in a stupid way you don't have
the instantiation right
and the message that i want to send
which is of course going to be treated
as heresy by all of the
uh people who are you know this the the
the
the people who have this energy that
there is a demarcation problem that you
can solve at the skeptic our skeptic
friends and our rationalist friends
no that's not how this game works the
real way this works is that the true
scientific method
right the scientific method is the radio
edit of great science
and the way the great science works is
every which way humans have ever come up
with reliable understanding of their
environment in their world
which may include dreams it may include
taking lsd in the case of carrie mullis
i don't know
it involves so many weird crazy things
that i'm i'm just i guess i'm sort of
sad that we keep trying
to uh neuter and and
and emasculate this subject when in fact
it's the messiness
and the fact that you don't know whether
agreement with the experiment is a death
knell or or in fact it's a false
indication that you're
on on the right path i think that we
just need to grow up and grow out of
both
uh emphatic poperianism usually
misinstantiated because popper wasn't as
dumb as people claim
and we also have to stop fetishizing the
scientific
method when we have the coulees of the
world
running around figuring out benzene
you know so many weird things contribute
to our
uh understanding of reliable information
in science
we've got to be more honest that there
is no such thing as the scientific
method the way you learn about it in
school
yeah i think the way it's taught in
school is is frankly
kind of silly uh the way i see it
my first post-doc mentor your graffelt
once said something that's always stuck
with me which is it's better to be wrong
in an interesting way than to be right
in a boring way so for example
schrodinger's
first failed hydrogen atom you know
einstein's first failed
general relativity formulation they were
wrong in an interesting
way and being wrong in an interesting
way is very very valuable for physics
second i feel and i thought that was a
bit of a sentiment of what you were
saying to eric is
you know humility is has to be at the
core of science
right not only should we be humble and
acknowledge that
everything we believe in might be wrong
even our pet theory that we just
published
but we should actively seek out
ways in which we can actually be proven
wrong it's kind of the opposite of a
politician right who
avoids saying anything you're sticking
your neck out
so that they can be proven wrong we
should aspire to
to we should really aspire to live
dangerously
we should have the mindset that the more
we force
ourselves to live dangerously and have
our theories potentially be proven
wrong right the more likely we are to
learn something interesting yeah so
absolutely just
on that front if you think about pop
paul linus pauling
racing watson and crick for the double
helix
both of them came up with a triple helix
with the sugar phosphate back
bone on the interior with the
nucleotides sticking out
if i recall correctly so there are
certain mistakes that may be canonical
on our way towards the truth and that
you actually have to go through the
valley of error
in order to to to scale the peaks of
success and insight
and what is absolutely
important about this and it goes back to
the funding conversation unfortunately
is that you need to have a tolerant
enough community that
people can afford to tell the truth and
continue in their quests
without worry that by stumbling they
will immediately you know there's this
old thing in the in the concentration
camps of uh
in death camps where if you coughed you
were gone
and so you know at some level this zero
tolerance for error
is something that really bothers me a
lot of these great old stories people
made error after error after error
on their path to becoming the people who
who
put things in final form and i think
part of what's going on
is that the one thing i'm going to
quibble with i loved what max just said
i think it was great but i i do have a
a caveat unfortunately because i think
he's going to say it better than
i can we have to stop fetishizing
humility
um because clearly this is not a trait
that
most people associate with the
theoretical physics community
to say the least what really is going on
is that physicists and great scientists
need two separate facilities they need
absolute
pathological self-confidence and
arrogance
you need to be able apparently eric
lander used to call in like
biologist mathematicians and say tell me
what's wrong with my idea
they would tell him what's wrong with
his idea he'd say thank you i was
worried that there was something really
wrong but none of you came up with it
you know so you can can you tell a
hundred of the smartest people that you
value
their opinion you're all wrong yes
that's absolutely important you have to
have the arrogance and you have to have
the humility which is what max was
saying
the real trick which we don't explain to
people
is regulated expression of arrogance and
humility
just the way like with the operon and
the pajama experiment
sometimes you're expressing something
sometimes you're repressing it
and i really think that the part of the
problem is
is that some of the people who are
incredibly modest and incredibly humble
what we need to do is to get them hyped
up on their own
brilliance other people who are
insufferable and don't
really seem to
i think it's clear enough i think that
the basic point is arrogant people need
more humility
humble people often need more
self-confidence and we we can't
keep extolling one virtue over the other
so on that note i do want to take some
questions we've had
a couple hundred dollars worth maybe
even a thousand dollars worth which is
going to go to your
gen's favorite charities we're going to
split that down the middle i want to
thank
uh people uh for asking these wonderful
questions let's do a couple of quick
ones and then i want to get into
uh a couple of topics that i'm
interested in just because how often do
i get to
get my two good buddies together in a
council of the wise
uh i want to ask um first of all a
question
about aliens which has come in from one
of my uh one of my listeners but i want
to twist it to something i'm interested
in that max has thought about a lot
which is the so-called simulation
hypothesis i had on jill tarter this
this uh past week or last week uh
talking about the signal from proxima
centauri that
was supposedly picked up she was rather
dubious about that
but this question of whether or not we
exist
as the as the life 2.0 and whether or
not life 2.0
ever becomes fully like life 3.0 is my
question
and what are your current thoughts max
about the simulation hypothesis first
maybe state with bolsterum you know
meant by this uh you know you've talked
about this a lot
but how much credulity should we have in
this and then i'm going to ask
eric about the ethics and the morale
morality of a simulatable uh
civilization so
in what ways would they not be or be
like gods first max simulation
hypothesis your thoughts
current status all right so let me first
explain
rostrum stimulation argument and then
explain why i think it's flawed
uh the basic argument starts by saying
well
if if if uh we're blob of quarks and
electrons
and our conscious minds are ultimately
all about information processing right
then
surely if you were actually simulated in
a computer so that the
information processing was exactly the
same maybe you're in
suppose you were in some future super
advanced computer game or whatever
you wouldn't know the difference of
course so maybe we are in a simulation
uh and then bostrom goes on to say well
in in this universe of ours uh
it's likely that eventually artificial
intelligence will advance
and and we're gonna help life spread
into
much of our observable universe and
there's gonna be massive amounts of
computations and simulations and
perhaps way more simulated minds than
real minds
and therefore if you're a random mind
having these experiences you are
stimulated
so you are probably living in a
simulation he's more careful on that
than lists all the caveats also
so there's nothing flawed with what he
wrote but uh
i i think the conclusion that we are
probably living in a simulation is false
and and to see where it starts to go
wrong
just note that suppose you buy it and
you say okay we are all in a simulation
now
having this conversation we can make the
same argument all over again
that oh in our simulated universe
they're going to be all these future
doubly simulated minds and they're much
more of them so we're probably double
simulated
right and then we can repeat and say
actually no we're typically oh quadruply
oh
we've simulated google flex times yeah
no no like
specs text times and you start to get a
sinking feeling that there's something
rotten here
[Music]
and and there is yes the the big mistake
is that
it doesn't matter at all how many
whether they're more stimulated or real
minds in in the
universe that we think we're in what
matters is what's going on in the
basement
universe right where maybe there is the
original simulation
and if we're simulated we have no clue
what that
universe is actually like so we should
have an open mind about this as
anything else but i would definitely not
uh
jump on the bad bag and say oh we're all
simulated on the other hand
if you're still worried that maybe you
are simulated
the conclusion is pretty obvious you
should live a really interesting life
so that the simulators don't get bored
and shut you down tegmark's wager
uh an update of pascal uh eric what are
your thoughts about simulation
hypothesis
is it uh valid and what if any
obligations would a master simulator
have
to his denison's or her it's denison's
let's be honest
it's very interesting to me that when we
talk
so there's the simulation hypothesis and
also the
rogue ai agi hypothesis
and we don't really connect these so as
the simulators we are terrified of
creating the gollum
the frankenstein monster that comes
after us
and uh and out competes us because we
are like
ants to its god-like intelligence and on
the other hand if we are the simulated
we're terribly frightened that we are
going to have the plug pulled out which
these are the same stories in some sense
but we're on both sides of them and
we're telling them from the point of
view of we're scared in both cases
i never hear us say is it ethical to
pull the plug
on the agi because what are you know
what are
are we do we have the right to kill
something off that may tend to
intend to kill us and uh what are our
obligations to this
to the simulators so i think that our
narcissism is clearly on display
in the simulation hypothesis i do think
though that in part
what it does is it takes the loss of
religion that we associate with
nietzsche
and the inability to construct god and
to reconstruct it inside of the one
sector of the economy that still seems
to be behaving as if it does didn't know
that everything came crashing down in
the early 70s which is the
computation communication sector and so
weirdly
like if you look at what's happened in
physics we've all moved towards
information you know maybe the
university is made of information well
it seems pretty clear that this has to
do with the fact that silicon valley or
which is now evaporating and
reconstituting in miami and austin or
whatever
um that this silicon valley ethos has
pervaded our philosophical thinking our
scientific
thinking maybe it's an attempt to get
money out of mark zuckerberg it's
unclear
but i do think that it's very unlikely
in my
to my way of thinking given the
important of importance of the calculus
and therefore
the continuum in most things that we do
that it would be harder to simulate this
world
than to build it and i think that that's
one of the reasons why i'm not
very excited about the simulation
hypothesis
because the easiest way to simulate it
is to construct the actual thing that
you're simulating
and i think in that framework we just
haven't
thought uh enough about it and when
we're sort of reaching for the most
obvious uh hypotheses the last thing i
wanted to say is that if we stopped
calling it the simulation
and started calling it the effective
theory we we distinguish
now thanks to you guys in
renormalization theory
that higher level theories that aren't
true we now call effective because
they're still useful we have it
dispensed with newton
we just call him effective rather than
fundamental
so we don't know what a fundamental
theory actually looks like but if you
imagine
that the classical world is in some
sense like a simulation
we have a quantum existence and the
quantum existence is hidden from us
and we we stumble around as mesoscale
phenomena in this classical world that
doesn't really
exist but kind of washes out of the
quantum
if you wanted a hypothesis i think that
that would be
kind of a really interesting thing does
that get to you philosophically if it
doesn't excite you maybe the idea is
that you're really here for the science
fiction rather than the science i don't
know
yeah that is uh that's something i've
thought about also yeah do we uh
if we right before we pull the plug on
max's uh super ai simulator
is going to scream and what would that
do to us is it like cooking
lobsters which i don't know anything
about that but uh max you want to have a
quick follow-up before we
start to wind down or are we good to go
with that that's right sure
i think there's been some amount of self
self-criticism
uh here so in that spirit
let's be honest we are not that ethical
as a species even though we love patting
ourselves on our head and pretending we
are
right we have done a lot of horrible
things in history
and even today we're still not that
ethical right
why why else is it that we've talked so
little about the people who died of
starvation in this year of 2020 and of
tuberculosis
then we have talked about the fewer
people who died of covet right it's
because those people were poor
and we didn't feel our ethics applied to
them as much as the richer people who
who died of covert 19. that's the the
sad truth
why do we talk so much less about the
suffering of factory-farmed chickens and
pigs than
than you know that we talked about
um good-looking actresses or whatever
it's because again
we're not maybe as ethical as we'd like
to be
but being shifting a little bit to
optimism i think we should aspire
certainly to
become more ethical and maybe uh
and i know i would say actually by far
the greatest ethical dilemma is what
we're gonna make of the whole
cosmic future because you know on one
hand
we have enough technology now that we
could drive all life on this we could
drive
humanity entirely extinct if we wanted
to
which would perhaps wipe out you know
enormous
amounts of positive experiences in life
for billions of years throughout much of
our universe right
or we could get our act together and and
help life spread from this planet and
flourish
beyond the wildest dreams of our
ancestors
for billions of years in this amazing
future and
this to me is the ultimate ethical
dilemma what are we going to do will we
squander that
you know squander this future or are we
going to seize it and i would like to
end with freeman dyson whom you just
mentioned
here because he was not only an
intellectual hero of mine but it was so
inspiring
that you know he would hang out and have
lunch with us
lowly mortal post-docs you know back
when i lived in new jersey and he used
to point out that look
you know you ain't seen nothing yet you
know life today in
our universe as far as we can tell is
still this is puny perturbation
on what looks mostly dead right and uh
yet intelligence has this power to
completely transform the physical world
look what entire intelligence has
transformed earth
since it showed up it's and
with artificial intelligence it could
even happen quite soon that much of what
we see out there
starts to come alive and
our universe starts to really wake up
and fulfill its potential
i find it incredibly inspiring to think
about
how we here in our lifetime on our
little spinning ball in space
you know actually have so much influence
over the whole future of ethics and and
yeah positive experiences in the cosmos
and that's the reason honestly honestly
that i spend
so much of my time on the future life
institute and and other efforts to try
to make sure that we steer the
technology
towards making the future awesome let me
just ask you one question
about that assuming that einstein more
or less holds into whatever the
fundamental theory
is and that the constraints that we've
come to live with under einstein
relativity like the speed of light
continue to hold and assume that
uh humans have to live under that do you
think given how far other good stuff is
away from us
that realistically we are going to be
able to figure out any way of
bootstrapping our way someplace
interesting out of our relatively
isolated solar system with very few
habitable surfaces
yes absolutely i actually geeked out on
that in a big way in chapter six of my
book life 3.0
where i just asked the question what if
we shift from being
having our technology limited by our own
intelligence to instead having our
technology limited by the laws of
physics
how much better can we do and yes you're
completely right there's still limits
presumably there's still a speed limit
speed of light
etc etc and because of dark energy
there's a limit to how
many atoms we can ever access out there
but the limits are just mind-blowingly
far above
what we have now right so first of all
going to other solar systems as a walk
in the park
with artificial intelligence going to
other galaxies is also work in the park
you can uh
and i put i had a lot of fun making just
some nerdy plots
to see how how much of our cosmos can we
actually get to
there are galaxies that you can see
right now at very high redshift
where sadly if our current understanding
of cosmology is true
it saw c but not touch because they
they're
going away from us so fast at an
accelerating rate that
no technology will get us there but
a significant fraction of the beach ball
behind the
brian keating is in play for us and i
would really hate it
if our earth originating life spends
its entire future just on this little
spinning ball
i can't stand to think about it and the
the i i can't
i personally want to get off of this and
and visit the neighborhood
but my feeling about this is that i'm
hoping against hope
that we have a way of going against
einstein and i have to say that even now
i can go against many many people but if
it's derock and einstein i
really really don't like it um
thanks for that answer yeah well guys
this has been just a thrilling thing for
me i always say on my channel you know
sam harris has this thought experiment
you know
if you could go into a chamber and there
was a button you could push and it would
instantly teleport you
to mars and you'd survive and come back
and the only catch is
right before you push it they have to
kill you so you don't have
uh two copies of brian keating lying
around uh would you push that button and
a lot of people would
and uh you know i thought about and i
said you know what actually i have that
ability to teleport
right now and it's called my children
and not only my children
uh but of biological nature uh but also
my ideological children those that i
influence
and i want to just thank you two for
being uh influences to me
uh ideological uh i'll call you guys
cousins because you're not that much
older than me
if if so at all but uh i want to thank
you guys for going into the impossible
it's now champagne o'clock where max
lives actually i've been on champagne
this whole day
already since the crack of eight i want
to just remind people
go and look at improve the news.org it
is one of the most
fun and delightful pieces of actionable
uh intelligence that you can use to make
2021
a better year than 2020. i had so much
fun with it
please go to eric weinstein's channel on
youtube
and also subscribe to the portal please
stay tuned for this
to this channel we're going to have
deepak chopra
in conversation with frank wilczyk
facilitated by me
uh that was pretty fun and uh i'm gonna
have both of them individually as well
as well as john preschool is coming up
not too uh long from now and i had giant
narlikar
who is a giant of cosmology as maxwell
no was one of the fathers of the steady
state universe i think it's important to
listen to our elders
as i've listened to you guys who are
barely older than me in this universe
please
like and subscribe to the brian key and
dr brian keating's youtube channel
also into the impossible on itunes
wherever you get it the portal
max tag marks universe it's one of the
most delightful places
in this corner of the multiverse and now
i can say
with quite a great deal of confidence
that i'm closer
to knowing the mind of god thank you
boys
happy 2021
everybody out there i wish it'd be a
healthy happy safe
uh new year for everybody
thanks for having us thank you and god
indeed it will be bye guys